Film Courage: Adam you came here in 2006? Filmmaker/Actor, Adam William Ward: Yes, I came
to Los Angeles in 2006. Yes my first day
actually in town I got hired at
DreamWorks in post-production. My brother
got me a job there so like day one I
like walked up the universal I was
looking for DreamWorks then and then
like I went over to the right gate
finally and they left me and I met the
head of post-production at DreamWorks
Marsh Marc Graziano at the time and I
told them you know I want to make a
filmmaker and all this kind of stuff and
they needed help at the time and he was
like you know what you want to work here
for a while we need a little extra help
and I was like it was like a 20 minute
conversation and then he hired me and I
worked there for a couple months on
disturbia which was shooting at the time
and then Indiana Jones is in
pre-production and then he also had what
I said called it's a movie with Ben
Stiller it's a cone under Coen Brothers
a the Farley Brothers yeah I was a
Farley Brothers movie and they did that
movie too but anyway I was running
dailies and doing all kinds of stuff
like day one and so it was kind of crazy
I just remember like in 1989 Ford Taurus
running dailies around town like I had
the 35 millimeter projected film in my
car
for Eddie Murphy's raw and so I was like
day 1 and I'm delivering this raw
footage you know of the 35 millimeter
I'm like how they trust me already -
like deliver this footage like if this
got lost you know they would never have
that 35 millimeter again so that was it
was very interesting that was day one
for me and so I worked there for a while
and then from there I ended up working
for Todd Phillips who did hangover road
trip starts getting hot all those movies
and I I worked in the front office for
them doing mostly script coverage so
like I did notes on hangover before
hangover ever came out and yeah I was I
was like heavily pushing to cut one of
the scenes in the movie they
cutting it later I don't know if it was
because of me or not but I was uh I
loved the script like they really want
to do a different movie at the time and
I was just like what about hangover
hangover every day I was I was so stoked
about hangover because it was such a
Rijal script at the time it's kind of
like a murder mystery comedy you know
and I'd the time no one had ever done it
and obviously the movie was huge so a
lot of people liked it so so you'd been
in town one day yes I was my first day
in town and my brother got me a meeting
with Mike Rossi owner the head of
post-production and it was just supposed
to be a general meeting and so I met in
and talked with him and we talked for 20
30 minutes and he knew that I was new to
town and he was just a really nice guy
and it was like we need help around here
do you want to work here it was my
birthday too actually so I know it was
October 18th 9 2006 so I know exactly
what day was so yeah and so you sorry
you'd come from Hawaii or you'd come
from Pennsylvania I came from Hawaii I
went to college in hpu Hawaii Pacific
University and yeah I came here to try
to make it in show business so so you've
been in you'd been in LA 24 hours what
was it like because I hear Hawaii
everybody's very relaxed and it's just a
totally different culture then how was
that it's very different but when you
first get here it's just so much
excitement you know like I think when
you first get that to Hollywood in Los
Angeles you're like there's just this
energy that like your dreams could come
true and like any turn of a corner you
know you can meet somebody that could
give you a film as an actor or as a
director or everyone around you is is so
important to you you know you don't know
who you're talking to half the time and
so there's just an excitement to it and
later on I mean I still love the city
but it's it's very much a different
feeling in a way of now that I've made
my my first feature while I got wasted
it's very much like I have a different
point of view of not so much like who
are you and what can you you know I used
somebody can make my dreams come true I
kind of have the feeling of like you
have to do it yourself
you have to make it yourself and just
make it happen so it's very different in
that way and aside from your brother
putting in a good word for you what do
you think help sort of seal the deal
because that helps but then that doesn't
know it gets people in the door doesn't
always get the people a job or able to
keep the job what do you think I think
you know I see it's funny because a lot
of people come here with a lot of
confidence come to Los Angeles and come
to Hollywood with tons of confidence and
slowly and slowly I see that beating out
of a lot of people you know they get
become people's assistants so they
whatever they do they get beaten down
like you're not so special you're not
good whatever but I I've always just had
undeniable confidence and I think when
you talk to people and you have such
confidence
maybe they scratch their head and go
maybe you're right or you know but
you've got to have that confidence in
yourself and and the fact that you won't
give up or and I've always had that I've
always had like you say I can't this
can't be done watch me do it
I'm gonna do it anyway so and that's
that's been true with mario whole career
really i mean while he got wasted there
was people that told me what the film
they said listen we shot while he got
wasted for 70 grand by the way i look so
it looks like a studio movie we shot
over 70 grand and there was people that
you know first i remember our first ad
told me is to listen the script great
but you can't do this okay you you way
over your head you don't have enough
money you have 38 locations you want to
shoot in 22 days you can't do this and I
just said well you're not the right guy
for the job
you know I'm doing this this is gonna
get done and and we did do it we'd shot
38 locations in 22 days and it was very
hard but we did it and I never gave up
and even though some people around me
wanted to give up at times we we did not
give up and we got it done what do you
think he told you that because I don't
think that was possible in his brain to
do that I don't think and so many people
want to make films you know but then
when you get in the thick of making a
film it's very hard I mean I was
sleeping two hours maybe three hours a
day
for a whole month straight you're
basically kind of killing yourself you
know and I was acting in the film so you
know the makeup artist is like I can't
make you look like you'd looked on day
one because you're killing yourself and
it's showing up on camera
you know the makeup can only do so much
so it's yeah you can't have give up in
your head cannot happen at all it can't
be a possibility or you will give up in
this town like people that come here and
say that I'm gonna give it a year and my
acting career you know or whatever I'm
gonna give it a year and see where I'm
at know if you have a back-up plan
you're gonna fail there's no backup plan
like there's no possibility of
everything else you need to constantly
be moving forward and thinking about how
I'm going to achieve this goal and and
that's all that that or you'll fail or
you'll give up so you know if it takes
30 years I have no backup plan that's
all that there is so that's that's kind
of the personality you gotta have and
the mentality you have to have
what keeps you here now in Los Angeles
good question um I love the city and
I've been lucky enough that I came here
my brother lived here but now pretty
much my whole family has moved here so
now I have family here so it's a little
different my sister's here my younger
sister and my parents are in Palm Desert
so it's not far so family in a way would
keep me here no matter what but I love
Los Angeles it's such a sprawled out
city there's all these different pockets
of cool things to do or hikes or
whatever so and the weather is beautiful
so you know I don't try to promote it I
know I never try to get more people to
move here because so many people move
here already so but a lot of people move
back back home yeah a lot of people give
up too and move away but because of the
weather I feel like a lot of people move
to Los Angeles in general
sure but no I I'm in the mecca of
moviemaking in the United States I mean
that's where Los Angeles is so I don't
know what kind of trials and
tribulations you'd have if you were in
Atlanta or somewhere else maybe there
there's enough people that I wouldn't
you know you have enough film people but
here I mean in my phone I have 10 DPS I
can call directors of photography Rian
calling they own a camera in an amine so
it's like here there's so many people
that are making films there's so many
people to own cameras it's really
saturated so to get a project off the
ground off the ground it's a lot easier
to get it off the ground as to where in
middle of America do you know anyone
that owns a red camera or Aria Alexa or
any of these kind of cameras it's
probably really hard to find somebody
that owned was owns one in like Nebraska
or something so here you're in a bar you
probably somebody in the bar why don't
your camera I mean it's just so it's so
saturated in that way so hopefully
they're sober enough to operate it but
yeah but do you have a goal list like do
you have a certain amount of things that
you know by this date I want to have
them completed I mean I want to make 30
movies in my life
it's whatever inspires me really I mean
I have in my phone I have ideas for
movies that go on and on I mean I must
have 20 or 30 ideas for features some
are fleshed out and some are really raw
just a one or two sentences but I also
have a TV show like I did so I came here
and I work for DreamWorks and then
worked for todd phillips and then I
realized it's funny because I realized
that people around me had want to be
directors or they want to be some
position in film and they weren't doing
it yet and I was like how long have you
worked here and oh I've been doing this
11 years but I want to be a film
director and I was like so I could be
you in 11 years I was like yeah I got a
stop so what I left Todd Phillips his
office I was like I want to act interact
so I went to acting school and I started
acting in every possible thing I could I
did 11 short films in 2009 and then I
was a lead in three independent feature
films in 2010 and when I saw the
independent feature films I realized
they weren't good enough and I thought
to myself I have to get behind the
camera if I really want to make my
dreams come true and I always planned on
getting behind the camera anyway
eventually but it just kind of pushed me
to do it sooner so I thought I was just
gonna produce an act and so I put I
managed to raise the money together to
shoot a TV pilot and I was gonna produce
we had a director and everybody the
director pulled out and it was his
script so I told the money people hold
on I'll write something else and we can
shoot that so I ended up writing three
guys in a couch which is a TV pilot that
I wrote and and ended up directing
because I couldn't find the director
everybody couldn't see the vision that I
had so I ended up directing it too so I
acted and directed and wrote it and we
shot it in 2011 it's actually on Amazon
Prime you can go watch it on Amazon
Prime and it's for free on there and
it's a 20-minute pilot it's a comedy
pilot I kind of I love Seinfeld growing
up and so it was kind of nice
version of Seinfeld you know my best
version of it I guess that I could do
and it's just about three guys trying to
rent out their couch for to make rent so
I mean the whole episode just couch
interviews they're interviewing people
to rent the couch so that was the pilot
episode and I have god I have in my
phone like 50 episodes of that show I
just kept writing ideas for that show in
that Jo Jo so hopefully I do another
show and use all those ideas eventually
but I did that TV pilot was the first
thing I ever directed and then I ended
up from that pilot someone at Fox saw it
and Fox called me and it was like hey it
was a subsidiary of Fox but it's on the
Fox lot called me and it was like hey
we'd really like to develop a new show
with you like this was really good for
your first thing so let's let's develop
something else so I came in every week
for like eight or nine months developing
new ideas with them for new shows and
eventually settling on a show called
parole officers which is about a guy who
gets arrested and he gets to parole
officers that are gonna help him change
his life background but he gets he got
falsely arrested for drugs so he really
has no problem with drugs and the two
parole officers are completely crazy
that take over his life and just totally
destroyed even more so we shot that into
that well hold on rewind Fox ended up
scheduling it for me to do a table read
they were like we're gonna give me a
million dollar budget to do the pilot
all this kind of stuff and then they
ended up pulling the plug and so the day
before the table read they were like we
have something similar now we're not
going to shoot this anymore
what they did not know is every time I
would come in with a script or an idea
we're not an idea but a script I was
copy writing it so I are I knew that I
owned the copyright on the show so okay
you have something similar but you're
not gonna steal my idea so I was like
heartbroken for a while I mean it's hard
to get over was eight or nine months you
know of me
my friends and everyone I'm doing a show
with foxy didn't read so for me it was
like it was very heartbroken when it
didn't happen but then I was like you
know what I'm gonna shoot myself
so three guys on our couch we shot for
five grand at the time on the red
cameras so this I actually ended up
shooting for five grand as well it's a
27 minute pilot that's also on Amazon
Prime now parole officers and so I ended
up raising the money independently and
we shot that TV pilot as well in 2013
and then from there there was I ended up
directing two short films for friends
and then it was like it's time to do a
feature so that's when Wally got wasted
got made so I'm hoping we can go back to
when you worked at Todd Phillips's
office and at what point did you have
that like wow I could be this person
here or this person here and they seemed
happy with their job maybe not maybe
they are but I don't want to have that
be me how did you like what can you kind
of take us through how long before you
left I think in the beginning I think in
the beginning it was just so exciting to
be there I mean like Angelina Jolie
would come in the office you know like
Angelina Jolie was in the hallway and
I'm like oh there's a pretty girl in the
hallway and then she's standing out
there for a while I'm like maybe this
woman's lost you know I'll go out there
she was pregnant at the time this
pregnant woman's in the hallway like
maybe she's lost so I went in the
hallway I'm like hey you okay like you
lost and of course once I get in the
hallway I'm like oh I'm talking to
Angelina Jolie she's like no I'm just
waiting I'm gonna go into a meeting
upstairs and I just wanted a moment by
myself and I was like okay no problem
you know I walked back in the office
she's right on the other side of the
class to me you know and there's no one
else around
so of course I'm like oh you know
Angelina Jolie is here on the computer
you know telling the office and then
like the guy played Hellboy at the time
he was coming in the office like and I
met so many people coming in the office
that we're making movies and actors and
so in the beginning it was just so
exciting to be there you know on the
post side of things I never would meet
movie stars I mean I met Steven
Spielberg in that but I wouldn't meet
like Angelina Jolie at DreamWorks at
post-production they just don't go there
but there was just so exciting I think
it took a while for the Excite
- we're off because I was doing script
coverage on like three scripts a day
they would expect three scripts a day
for me to read and do coverage on them
and and I'm a slow reader - so it wasn't
easy flurry but constantly trying to
break it down and write a you know a
one-page synopsis of the whole movie and
and greenlight it or not greenlight it
like if you didn't get through me the
people above me never read it so that's
how it would work so if I don't like
your script the person above me doesn't
like the script it's never gonna read
the script you know and then on top of
that it was just kind of crazy to me in
a way because these people have agents
their managers they're up but if you
don't get through the guy at the front
desk you don't get to Scott Budnick at
the time where Todd Phillips or anyone
else so I'm literally like
green-lighting someone's life or not but
if I send it up the ladder and it's not
good my now I'm not considered a very
good script coverage guy so you're bone
my own ass is on the line so it was very
interesting at the time I think it took
three months before the excitement of it
all war of everything kind of wore off
and I started asking more questions you
know and Todd Phillips assistant at the
time was his assistant for like nine
years and I found out he was a film
director and I saw some commercials he
shot and some other stuff and he was
like yeah I want to be a film director
and I was like but you've been his
assistant for nine years like clearly
he's not gonna help you make a film you
know so he's not gonna help me make a
film I gotta go make a film out on my
own so that's kind of the epiphany that
I had that no one here if you're not
doing the job that you're supposed to be
doing they can't see like something I've
learned in Hollywood since I've been
here people don't see potential it's not
something that they see it's either
you've done it or you haven't done it
it's very rare that someone can see
potential of what you've done
like there's no excuses it's like you've
even they're made in a phenomenal movie
or you've made a mediocre movie and then
they think you're gonna always make a
mediocre movie so or I guess in any
position that you've done they could
they don't see potential like oh you had
a really good moment here or there or
your budget you didn't have enough money
they don't see the excuses it's either
it's good enough or it's not why do you
think that is do you think it's because
there's just everything goes too fast
and there's too much money on the line
they don't have time to like nurture
something or I think it might have been
different back in the day they might
have nurtured people more back in the
day I mean like all the studio's now are
corporate I mean like Viacom you know
like all these big companies owned the
studios it's not really owned by an
individual anymore
back in the day paramount was it
paramount I think was owned by a guy
that would go to all the premieres with
a lion I mean it was one person's
decision and a few people belong and I
think in was that the 90s or something I
mean all the studio's got bought up by
big corporate companies everything's
powered by money so since everything is
powered by money are you gonna take a
chance on someone who's already
delivered or someone who has potential I
mean if your ass is on the line you're
gonna go with the safe bet so part of me
understands that but I think also it
takes a very special person to see
potential you know I don't think
everyone can see potential it's about is
that it's almost a rare skill compared
to have the talent like only some people
are very very talented some people only
have that one gift of seeing talent -
and half the people that I meet that are
at the top still they don't have that
gift like they shove 20 40 million
dollars in advertising on a movie in the
movie Maibaum well somebody else might
have been able to see that it was gonna
bomb but they couldn't see it but they
have the title of the head of the studio
or whatever so it's just interesting to
see how certain things happen and I know
people in positions that tell me all
kinds of stories were you know I'm like
really I saw the trailer - that I have
no idea what that movie's about and it's
a two minute trailer like if I don't
know what your movies about at all and
it's a two minute trailer it's a really
bad sign you know and you're putting 40
million dollars in advertising that
blows my mind
but anyway can we go back to your script
reading days first off what qualify
someone as a script reader like how do
you how do they know you're ready to be
doing coverage it's so funny nothing
nothing qualified me at all I got the
job and they started shoving scripts in
my hand I had no qualifications for that
whatsoever and that's the truth I got
better as I went like I'm sure my first
synopsis was kind of like what the hell
is this
but I'm doing three a day so eventually
I'm getting better and better and better
and that's the thing too like nothing
nothing qualifies you in this industry
like if you want to make films if you
want to act whatever you want to do
there's no qualification people were
like it's not like every other job and
so but at the same time the problem is
the whole world doesn't it is the same
when it comes to experience that's the
difference it's not the same as a
qualification as oh I went to Harvard ah
oh of course you're qualified to do this
job or not and it's more about oh you've
done 15 movies I've seen that you have
the qualifications in the way that I put
a camera on you and you're not going to
get nervous you know I mean you're gonna
deliver and and all that kind of stuff
it's very different in that way and
really the people I see succeed other
people that never give up and keep keep
learning and getting better and better
and better and and it's very rare to see
that because certain people get to a
certain age and then when I have babies
they want to do certain things and
certain things are pulling them in
different directions and you know it's
very hard to keep trying to do the same
thing if you haven't hit the ideal of
what you you know imagine but a lot of
people come here and say I'll give it a
year like I said before but it's like
would you if you wanted to be the CEO of
Apple would you give it a year because
that's what this is if you're like the
lead in the TV show you're a CEO of that
company now you're the face of that TV
show everyone is putting millions of
dollars behind you so you better be good
really good you know and have no work
your way up and and and you know be the
CEO of that company because that's what
you are at that point so that's you know
and the same thing with the director in
a movie like if you they give you 20 or
40 million dollars or 100 million
dollars to make a movie I mean the money
speaks for itself you're a CEO of that
company
you're completely in charge of making
that a good movie or a bad movie at that
point so it takes time to get that good
and to get people to believe in you you
know so you didn't have like sort of the
qualifications that you thought you
would have had to have been a script
reader or you were just surprised that
they entrusted you um it was it was
mind-blowing to me because before that
point we would me and my brothers
writing scripts back in Oregon when I
had no connections whatsoever and we
would meet a guy that could get it to
somebody else I was now on the other
side of it all reading the scripts and I
realized when I was writing him they
were handing it to the intern that has
absolutely no qualifications it might
just not like my script no you then
mostly everyone reading a script has no
qualifications whatsoever they read it
then if they like it because of their
opinion it goes up the ladder with
someone else who has more experience
than what else has more experience and
eventually maybe someone who really can
look at a script and dissect the whole
thing but you have to get through all
these other layers of people that really
don't know what they're doing so you
better it better be so good that they
read it and are just so intrigued by it
but it also can just be you ran into the
right people they'll write three people
that loved your script or loved your
idea or whatever so no mostly everyone
reading a script has no qualifications
in the beginning at a studio so the
bottom layer people have no
qualifications and so would you ever
stop reading a script or you had your
job was to read it all the way through
were you doing three scripts a day so I
mean if I read and it's just horrible
the first 20 pages I'm gonna try to sum
up the script the best way possible I'll
go read the last 15 pages and most of
the people in the office would tell me
that they say like somebody in there I
remember was like just read the first
ten in the last ten decide if you like
it and then you might read it but
otherwise that's all the matters like if
it's not good they're like get rid of it
you know so yeah so I ended up doing
that some times and I felt bad for
people you know but if it was bad it was
bad you know I mean that's the thing
like when you have a stack next to you
this 20 scripts am I really gonna not
everyone's gonna get an opportunity so
first 20 pages there's no bad the whole
thing has to be amazing
so the first 20 pages are bad will then
your scripts done it's not gonna get to
the next level so and actually now that
I've made a film distribution companies
tell me like that first 10 minutes of
your movie better be amazing like
because people will turn it off on these
streaming platforms so you better put a
lot of your budget in that first 10
minutes have a chase see and have a gun
scene have whatever captures them high
drama you know something to drag that
audience in and capture them you know
because everybody's attention span is so
short nowadays so yeah and then what was
coverage like if you even if it was just
the first ten in the last ten how much
like what are you filling up on a piece
of paper of coverage what was it like so
I wouldn't actually write on the script
I would just write a one-page synopsis
and try to basically make an outline of
the script really if you did coverage on
your own script you'd be saving people a
lot of time to be honest with you
because Hollywood people want your movie
in one sense and then if they're
intrigued by the one sentence they'll
want to read a paragraph so if you write
one sentence it sums up your movie great
then write a paragraph that sums up your
movie great then have a one-page
synopsis that sums up your movie better
and then have the script and if you
handed that to somebody they would love
you to death because and you can master
getting each one of those great because
otherwise the interns gonna run white
write your one-page synopsis when you
could have done it yourself in a way or
your one-liner or your one paragraph or
whatever so that's kind of how it is and
so then you got the hangover it landed
on your desk or someone else already
loved hangover I didn't I didn't green
liked hangover they already had hangover
they liked hangover that was one of the
two scripts that they were developing at
the time and they were like it was that
and another script called manwich and
when they were like these are our two
movies that were gonna make check them
out eventually but at the time all the
excitement was over the man which
movie's not over the hangover
and that was the next movie they're
gonna make next not hangover and I was
constantly like and maybe Todd always
knew he's gonna do hangover I don't know
I wasn't really talking to Todd that
much I mean he came in the office and
once in a blue moon you know Scott
Budnick was his partner at the time and
so I had a lot more interaction with him
and for me when I read it it was just
you know it was very funny and it was it
was a page-turner because it's a murder
mystery they're trying to find their
friend so it was all solid it was good
and someone else actually wrote that
script and then Todd and his partner
rewrote that script so they didn't
actually write the first draft of it so
and they went on I think to do some
other movies and stuff but yeah so then
eventually you saw that you could become
that guy or that girl and you'd be
making a nice living but you wouldn't be
doing exactly what you want to do did
you plan to get out or was it one day
where you just throw a bunch of papers
up in the air and walked out I what
happened no no I mean I was only at each
place for like three months anyway and
both of the places I mean both places it
was it was kind of a short-term thing
anyway so it wasn't like I had to go
home leaving it was kind of like wow the
time is up that you were supposed to be
here anyway so that was nice in a way it
didn't I didn't get promoted you know I
mean like oh yeah it's very hard for
people to turn down money when you first
get here so a lot of these people it was
like oh I know I mean 50,000 oh now I
got a hundred thousand now you got two
hundred thousand I'm making three
hundred thousand a year I have a wife
how am I supposed to leave this job you
don't I mean your money dependent on
that job and I'm lucky that an offer me
position because I might have tried to
embrace it you know which a lot of
people do embrace their nine-to-five
jobs and give up on their dreams and I'm
lucky that I was raised by my father and
and my mom and my dad always instilled
in me you can do anything you want to do
you just have to go for it and not take
no for an answer so that's that's kind
of my mentality with life you got it to
go do it did you see that in him and my
dad my dad actually was a musician back
in the day and he he was almost the lead
singer of Aerosmith when I
Smith aegyo was having drug problems and
stuff and there was a guy named Arthur
man basically that put a contract in
front of my dad and was like I want you
to perform in every club bar stage from
here to China and my dad had
unfortunately him my mom was pregnant at
the time and he was he decided to and he
had a real job and so he gave it up and
he became a family man really and the
the same contract
Arthur man gave it to Bon Jovi so Bon
Jovi ended up becoming Pancho via my dad
ended up being a debt and and shortly
after unfortunately my dad got in a bad
car accident and so he ended up being a
stay home dad and my mom worked and so
my house is very reversed I guess in the
80s of the more people the mom stayed
home well my dad was the stay of dad so
it was very different in that way and
kind of crazy though cuz he trained my
sister how to sing and so my sister is
easy ward she's a big-time singer and so
you know the next generation still made
it as a singer she signed to Hollywood
Records which is Disney and she's
working on her third album now so it
kind of he passed up his music dream but
she accomplished it so it's kind of nice
to see that full circle for him you know
so did you see the Jim Carrey
documentary which one I saw one where he
did the man on the moon he's on about
that one yeah and he type ritty sure he
talks about his dad I think his dad was
he did talk about his dad yeah I
remember his dad so his dad gave up his
dreams to be a comedian in the Jim
Carrey documentary and he did the 9 to 5
and then the 9 to 5 that was the steady
job laid him off so he realized at that
point that there was no safe bet and
that is true man it's completely true I
see that all the time with people that
they really hold onto their nine-to-five
job but nothing's guaranteed nothing's
guaranteed so it's like you gotta take
chances you gotta you know that but
that's life people you know you gotta
make mistakes too and that's why a lot
of people I know so many filmmakers that
aren't willing to do their first feature
because they're too scared to make a
mistake you know it's like no you got to
make it
if you fail you fail or if you make a
movie that's not the best you can do
great learn from it and make another
film but I know more than one director
that is phenomenal that has never done a
feature you know and I've known them for
ten years you know do you think it's the
money aspect I could see why that would
be scary but what do you think it is I
think people have all kinds of excuses
you know I mean I think money is kind of
usually the number one excuse I don't
have enough money or I can't get enough
money to make the the feature but well I
mean what are you doing to try to get
the money you know there's that aspect
it a lot of them go I don't have the
right script and I'm not a script writer
you know a lot of that kind of stuff and
that's one of the reasons of while I got
wasted it was like Seth my writing
partner seth Himes basically he wrote a
script and he came to me and I didn't
really particularly like it I liked the
first 20 pages and I was like the first
20 pages was slightly similar to while
he got wasted and I was like I thought I
really thought the movie was gonna go in
this direction because in the first
three pages it's about three guys that
accidentally killed somebody and then
the movie will win a totally different
direction and I was like I really
thought you were gonna kind of reamp
weekend at Bernie's and put hangover
together and kind of do this like new
kind of comedy movie because that's what
we ended up doing and he was like no and
after he was heartbroken for a while
because I I told him my honest opinion
he came back and was like well let's
write the idea that you have and so that
was like 2014 and so we were living
together at the time we were roommates
and I laid out the whole movie in one
night with him and I came up with the
structure of it and then he didn't and
we didn't end up writing it he ended up
moving out later and then like six
months later he came back and he wrote a
first draft and like a day or two
because he's a very fast writer and
there was like one scene in the first
draft which was the drive-thru scene in
the movie that was phenomenal and which
was great because I could literally he
did my outline though so it had the
correct outline but it just wasn't as
good as it needed to be yet but it was
nice because I always try to stick on
the positive because any artist is very
sensitive usually and so I was like
listen this is phenomenal but the drive
through scene is amazing and the whole
movie needs to be as good
the drive-thru scene so we need to do
rewrites so then we did then we'd ended
up doing rewrites for about eight or
nine months to a year on the script and
and getting it to where we thought it
was strong and then we ended up trying
to get you know I had enough connections
in Hollywood that I was trying to send
it to anybody that could help me make it
at the time
which is where mostly every filmmaker
ends up dying because they're trying to
hand their project to somebody else to
help make it and that's usually fallen
on dead ears so we did that and there
was one studios talking about making it
and some other stuff it was just talk
and eventually I said you know what we
can't keep doing this I got I let's just
do it ourselves you know so we ended up
raising the money ourselves selling
units to the movie for a certain dollar
amount you owned a percentage of the
movie and I was gonna sell units to
anybody I could sell units to I sold
them to doctors I sold them to dentists
I sold them to somebody in France I sold
them to somebody in Mississippi I sold
them anywhere I could sell them and talk
to people and you know talking to people
and convince them to hand me a check is
never easy but I always tell people I'm
one of the luckiest people you ever meet
and people seem to like me and trust me
so I'm lucky in that aspect but I
delivered I delivered the movie like I
promised I would so we raised the money
took like a year maybe a year and a half
to raise the money some not all the
money we wanted to but 70 grand
well 70 grand yes but Seth my partner
actually was coming up with 40 of that
probably so we only raised like 30 of it
and unfortunately Seth was in a bad
business deal and I actually did not
know that so I was like we have the 70
grand we can start so I did all the
casting in the movie already I found all
the locations we found I found 38
locations for free in Los Angeles
it's like unheard of right how do you do
that meeting well we have drive-throughs
we have grocery stores we have festered
restaurants we have nightclubs it took
time you know and I didn't want to put
dates down for the film until I found
locations and found all my actors did
not want to have a date because I was
working every day on it any
I didn't need a time to like push me I
was working on it every day so I didn't
put a date down for the film yet but I
would every location we needed I would
go out there and it was a fast-food
restaurant I'd walk into every fast-food
restaurant I could and be like hey can
we use this space to shoot you know I
can I speak to the manager and talk to
them chains basically would all turn me
down it's a corporate decision so I
learned very quickly I need to find
mom-and-pop places mom and pop grocery
stores mom about fast food places
basically I need to be able to talk to
the person that's making the decision
and not have a million you know lines to
get to who I need to talk to and it was
just convincing people with passion
really and it was my first feature my
butt was on the line and I think they
saw how much excitement I had and a lot
of people just agreed to help me and and
then sometimes it was a connection
through somebody else and you know at
the grocery store was a connection
through Seth it was a friend of his from
college who knew somebody who owned a
grocery store and they gave us
permission to shoot there and then we
went there on the day and they didn't
know who we were
you know somebody didn't even tell him
but they saw the camera in the crew and
they were excited and they ended up
letting a shoot there I don't even know
if we need a permission to shoot there
because they didn't know who we were and
we shot the grocery store when it was
open so it was like well my actors were
joking and that we have up a 35 minute
documentary on YouTube actually people
can type in wall-e got wasted behind the
scenes and or pop right up it's the 35
minute a little documentary about how we
made the film but one of the actors in
the documentary is like live theater you
know because there's homeless people
walking by there's regular people
walking by in the middle of the shot
when we're shooting you know but we made
it work you know and yeah so just
convincing every location to let us
shoot there and some of these locations
would back out the day before because it
would be like like the fast-food
restaurant was like I need to come there
tomorrow night between said oh you'd
come after you closed we closed
ten I said okay he said well how long
you need to be here he's thinking I need
to be there like an hour you know no we
need to shoot until the Sun comes up
like I need as much time as possible so
normally we'll try to shoot 12 hours but
I have the Sun so we'll shoot from 10
p.m. to a 5 a.m. and he's like oh I have
to stay or two or five hey it happens
like he immediately was like I don't
want to do this anymore and I was like
listen you you can't bail on me like if
you bail on me I have nothing I'm
completely screwed so I would convince
him to stay basically and that's that
would happen a lot so you know rewind
all the way back to Seth getting that
money stolen from him I that happened so
I thought we were shooting the movie for
70 grand and and to rewind Seth had a
business Seth was gonna put in 40 grand
stole that 40 grand so he didn't know
until the first day of shooting so
basically the whole first day of
shooting you see photos and videos of
him and he's you could see he's like
having a nervous breakdown it's like
eyes like half open and you know because
he has to us to tell me that he lost all
that money and so we have our first day
of shooting and we finally get back
because he moved back into my apartment
to shoot the movie and he comes in my
room after like 14 hours of shooting of
the day and he goes he just completely
is like is destroyed and he's like I
lost all the money we haven't shut the
movie down and I was like Seth I got to
tell you there's nothing in the world
that can stop me from shooting this
movie at this point like no we're not
gonna stop I used a 30 grand
and we'll put the rest on credit cards
me and you will open credit cards I'm
gonna finish the movie put everything we
possibly can on credit cards but we will
not stop the movie and he would here in
my room was like we're gonna shut down
the movie I'm gonna move from away from
Los Angeles and I'm done with this dream
I'm never gonna do it again and I was
like no you're gonna finish your dream
and ever gonna drive forward and I
wouldn't let him quit I was like we have
to do this and so that's what we did we
put the rest of the movie on put 40
grand or something on credit cards and
30 grand we used to pay the crew and the
people we needed to pay it and we
finished it so yeah you would said 30
feature films is one of your goals
um that's in my head I know that I want
to do a lot of movies III don't have a
set at 30 and my you know I say that to
people so they understand that I'm doing
this for the rest of my life and I'm
gonna make a lot of movies and I think
it'll get easier and easier so
eventually I might make a movie a year
you know I mean but it's one of my team
around me and my finance ears and all
these kinds of things are moving faster
you know now it'll be it'll be in the
beginning it'll be less movies because
it's harder to make a movie now you know
it's harder to raise the money it's
harder to you know find the right crew
and all that kind of stuff but as I make
more and more things there's certain
crew members that I'm like yeah I'll use
him every time as long as he's available
you know I'm gonna use the same script
supervisor I want to use the same you
know gaffer I want to use whatever so
you you get a team going on as you make
more and more things and that's part of
the learning too you know because when
you're on a movie
everyone's sleep-deprived you know I
mean everyone's it's rough it's it's a
rough situations everybody's underpaid
and overworked
so you see people's true colors some
people lose it some people get angry
some people curse and you really don't
want it affects the movie you know you
really don't want negativity on a set it
spreads like wildfire I've been in
enough movies to know
once someone person starts complaining
other people start complaining and then
they start making in front of the movie
and then the whole thing goes shitty so
I try to get rid of negativity on my set
and hopefully I can fire the person or
get rid of them if it's my movie and
just get rid of them because it's like
well if you don't want to be here you
should just go you know and replace them
I had to replace had to kick one person
off my set and I've only had to fire one
person in my career so I'm lucky that
way but I try to vet people pretty well
but sometimes when you're in the middle
of it too it's very hard to get rid of
somebody you know in the middle of
making a movie try you know if you're in
the middle of a war you can't exactly
replace the guy shooting the gun next
year if he's bad so you just got a good
role with it sometimes but then you
won't use that person again you'd use
somebody else because keeping your cool
and having a positive attitude is so so
important well and there's a lot of
people that love to
in the quote vein of good advice tell
you things and you're never sure what
their angle is there's a lot of agendas
here and so I think that I find it
interesting that you had someone tell
you that you couldn't do the film and
they were just quote trying to be honest
with you and maybe they were but were
you able to then kind of like brush that
off and keep going or is it kind of fuel
you and chip on your shoulder a little
bit I think anyone who's gonna make it
in this industry like people telling you
you can't do it has to be your fuel
because you're gonna hear that a lot if
you're an actor if you're director
whatever position you are especially the
the more higher up creative positions
people are gonna doubt you and if you
let that discourage you you're not gonna
get to where you need to be and even if
you believe some of the things they say
you have to learn you have to admit to
yourself that you're learning you're
always learning to get better you know I
mean I've seen interviews of Steven
Spielberg he says he's still learning
you know I mean so everybody's learning
as they go and take it easy on yourself
you know in my opinion you know while he
got wasted people seem to love the movie
and they laugh a lot but is it the best
movie I'm ever gonna make I hope not I
hope I get better and make even better
movies you know and everything that I
learned on this movie I can take to the
next movie you know so do you have a
barometer for when you think that you've
quote-unquote made it that's a good
question I think a lot of people have a
really tough time with that too because
I even see interviews of big actors and
stuff and they there's the struggle is
so real they have so many years of not
working or trying to get a job that even
when they become a movie star or a TV
star
they're constantly trying to take as
much work as possible they don't want to
turn anything down they're scared to
make a mistake because the moment you
turn something down you might not work
for a year so I think everyone has a
struggle with trying to get where the
pinnacle of where you want your career
to go I'm lucky because I I mean at this
point in my career and I think for the
rest of my career I never
I don't know I would do this for free so
it's a it's a little different you know
like a lot of people they hang on to
money or this and that and for me if I'm
not motivated by the creativity of it I
don't think I could do it I've turned
down jobs already where people want to
pay me to direct things and I I don't
vibe with the material I I just can't do
it and there's something I've learned in
my life in general if I'm not heartfelt
about something I can't do it like you
know in my life I try to get my I got my
real estate license and I did other
things but without the passion I'm just
not effective compared to something I'm
effective about you can't stop me when
I'm creative and passionate about
something but when I'm not it's very
easy to stop me those is that you're
Libra scales you know I think that more
comes into play with my negotiating
skills with people you know and and like
a lot of the movie was negotiating you
know and the scales is like well what do
you want you know try to figure out what
they want and if I can help them get
what they want either promise them that
I'll help them later or give to them
what they want now but what I don't have
right now is money so whatever I got to
do to get you to help me at the moment I
will do but money I don't have to give
to you so it has to be something else so
you know and like you hire a DP but he's
only DP TV shows or he's only done this
or that but he wants a feature you got
to find that person you know you got to
find the people that they want what you
want and that's the reason that they're
helping you you know you you know they
haven't done a feature or whatever you
know and same with actors you find a
really talented actor that hasn't been a
lead in a feature yet well he's gonna
show up every day for free if he want
him to because he's doing his dream to
just like you're doing your dream and
that's a problem for a lot of people
they go oh please help me and they go up
to the people at the top and want them
to help you well these people are making
a living they have no reason to take a
chance on you it's the people that
you're left and the people to your right
that you need to depend on and build and
grow together do you think that part of
making it is never feeling satisfied
because then you're you're always
looking for that next thing and if you
were complacent or content with
something you wouldn't I think a lot of
people I think happened that they have a
pinnacle of what they want in their head
for me like I said I would do this for
free I love doing this so I would just
keep doing it whether you know I
secretly I mean I gotta convince people
to give me money to make movies
sometimes and I do and I I mean what I
say when I think it's gonna make money
but I would do it if I didn't make a
dollar so I love telling stories I love
seeing the reactions that people laughs
I love you know I don't want to always
do comedies but comedies are very
rewarding because you know if it's good
or bad if people because they'll either
laughing or they're not so that's one
thing about everything I've done so far
has been mostly comedy that I've
everything that I've written and
directed it's been comedy and it's very
easy in a theatre to know that they're
liking it or they're not liking it so
it's been interesting with while I got
wasted did you have to do redo the first
10 minutes to appease the distributor or
was it already sort of built in because
you knew that so while I got wasted
actually we got offers from a lot of
distribution companies but you ended up
self distributing so we actually are
self distributing the movie we don't
have a distributor I we went through an
aggregator to get on all the platforms
right now we're exclusively on Amazon
people can get it on Amazon read and buy
it on Amazon I will go on iTunes I think
a video demand Vudu and a bunch of other
platforms here in the next week or so I
believe and we just did it through an
aggregator you pay an aggregator and
they put it on the platforms and because
mostly all the distribution companies
that we talked to none of them were
going to put any money in advertising
and I was like well what are you
actually doing you know and they would
come up with things like oh you know all
the big companies because we're a
distribution company that you'll get
higher on the algorithms to be seen by
people and I'd be like well where's the
proof of that I mean like you're telling
me this magical story of like oh I
signed with you everyone's gonna see my
movie on the platform compared to paying
an aggregator to getting on there but
there was absolutely no proof to that it
was just something that distributors
would say and I was like
there's no proof to it I can't I can't
drink the kool-aid in an event so that
and you know we had we have money that
we're putting in advertising so we're
doing that ourselves and also we
wouldn't see now that we paid an
aggregator we can see how you know from
the advertising who actually buys the
movie on the platform well we can't with
Amazon unfortunately their algorithms
isn't as good but on iTunes and some of
these others that we should be able to
run an advertisement they can click on
the advertisement and then we can follow
to see if they actually buy or rent it
but Amazon unfortunately can't do that
yet hopefully they fixed that but yeah
we decide not to go with the distributor
and distributors would want they want
someone 20 percent someone 30 percent
someone 40 percent and some of them I
mean that's the thing if you're an
independent movie and you're not going
to put any money in advertising and I
put it any energy in the advertising
game no interest in it then some of
these distribution companies are a good
option because they put 10 sometimes 20
thousand into getting you and all the
platforms and all the countries and all
these kinds of things and you don't have
to put out that 20 grand but if you want
to bank in yourself which you know me
and Seth we're talking about it's like
we've backed in ourselves every step of
the way here you know from making the
movie ourselves to now distributing
ourselves we banked in ourselves so
let's just continue to do that and I
hustled my butt off to try to get the
word out and get people to know about it
and we casted seven big social media
people in the movie we have seven big
youtubers instagramers that would
hopefully spread the word and they do
videos and stuff on it too so you have
that as well but it's exciting it's all
it's exciting getting the word out there
and working on it and I see the numbers
come in every day you know there's
sometimes we have 150 people rendered by
the movie in one day and it's like you
know some some weeks it's like that
every day and like wow on a Wednesday
140 people paid money to watch my movie
it's insane to me it's crazy and
rewarding and exciting you know what are
some things you learned in the last five
years that you wish you knew in the
first five years
moved here some of the places that some
things have already said but number one
is the banking yourself if you really
believe in yourself you have to bank in
yourself and what that means is you
can't depend on an external person to
make your dreams happen if you want to
make them happen you go make them happen
yourself now actors some actors are very
much independent of a studio or film
maker if you're not a filmmaker yourself
but even an actor in a way you could
find the right director you could find
money people you could then produce and
put a whole project together but it's
the bank in yourself it's to start
learning and figure out what you need to
do and do it do it yourself we've Wally
watt waist have we done completely
outside of the studio system and it
would have never got made if I was I'd
still be scratching my head handing in
descriptive people and even though
people love the script I still be
handing it to people and even the people
that might want to make it they weren't
gonna make me the director who are you
so I had to do it to learn and to prove
myself you know that's another thing
that I've learned is people like I said
people don't see potential you have to
show them there I I'm the same person I
was five or six years ago when I was
telling people you know I'm gonna be a
film director they don't really believe
me they don't really know there's so
many people that say things in this town
now they treat me with totally different
respect and they look at me like a
filmmakers so it's very interesting in
that way it's like you know what you're
going to do or what you're capable of
so go do it and show people don't don't
trust that they see it - they're not
gonna see it you have to show them what
would you say the people though that
aren't as confident with themselves
maybe they're not confident with the way
they look I mean you're handsome man
you're tall you present yourself well so
it's easy for me to see why people aside
from talent would want to believe in you
but not everybody has that so what would
you say to people that don't feel like
they have it um it's funny though cuz
I'm motivated mood that kind of goes
into your motivation I'm actually
motivated by people not believing me in
a way I mean I have a lot of support and
a lot my father and my mother and my
family believe in me a lot but I'm
actually more motivated by people that
tell me I can't do something and I don't
know I don't know how healthy that is
but that's what it is and I think I
think ultimately if you're not you have
to start looking at yourself yeah then
the start of the work doesn't start with
with making films the work starts in ER
and then you need to go look at yourself
analyze yourself and really build
yourself up maybe with positive
reinforcement every morning metod maybe
meditation whatever it is build yourself
up to believe the belief that you can do
it because without the belief I mean
you're not gonna do it you know if you
believe what people tell you you know I
think everybody who's ever done anything
amazing they were told they can't do it
and if they believe that they would
never would have done it so you know the
fact that it's never been done before it
just makes me excited that you know I'll
be the first you know how you know so
it's more challenge when someone polite
or not says no to you because then
rather than somebody who seems more like
oh yeah that sounds great to you that's
maybe not enough of a challenge I don't
look forward to it it's not like I'm
like oh please tell me no but it's kind
of like I don't know it's you know it's
a fire inside you or you tell me no and
I'm like why do you want to get in my
way I'm gonna win you know no matter
what so I'm gonna make this happen and
you know and I have good intentions with
it I'm not I'm not trying to defeat
anybody but I have my goals and my
dreams and and and my belief and it is
is you know you can't your belief in you
and what you want to do just can't waver
it cannot and that's the first place to
work on if you don't have that belief
you need to work on it and get it before
you even take on the beast of a feature
or any dream you know that you have
because I'm sure curing cancer the
people working on it right now they
believe they're gonna cure it no matter
what and you couldn't tell them you
couldn't
Vin's them that they weren't gonna cure
it even though they haven't done it yet
but that's the kind of belief that you
need to have and determination to
accomplish your dreams no matter what
they are since your time in Hollywood
what 2006 when have you been your most
broke huh when I first got here I
actually slept in my car one night when
I first got here I stay with my brother
for a while and his girlfriend at the
time was tired of me being there and so
they were like you got to get out and so
I slept in my car one night or two and
then I ended up staying with another
friend for a while in the beginning yeah
I I've always been decent with saving
money I've been lucky in that way so it
didn't take long for me to get a job
waiting tables and start saving up and
stuff but I've never been like $50,000
in credit card debt I said for making
the movie so I mean that was probably
our brokest point was after we made the
movies by that's the truth of it because
we had $40,000 of credit card debt and
at that point I had already saved up I
saved up 15 grand to put into the movie
so I already put my all my savings into
the movie and we had 40 grand of credit
card debt
so that was probably my brokest point is
after we made the movie but you don't it
was I never I never second-guessed at
once and I was proud and happy to do it
so so you slept in your card you
remember what street with town that was
that's interesting huh where was I think
I was on El Segundo that's why I live
down in South Bay now and Redondo Beach
and I ended up sleeping in my car that
first night at all my stuff at it it was
pretty crowded but I was 23 at the time
so you could almost get away with it
nowadays I think I'd be like wake up you
know once you hit your early thirties
you're not quite the same anymore but
yeah that was that was my hardest time
in LA and not knowing anybody other than
my brother you know when I first moved
here I had no friends I didn't know
anybody and and eventually you start
kind of getting a family
you know I was lucky I I did acting
school and so every you're surrounded by
people that are going through the exact
same thing that you're going through
starting out in LA and and so you kind
of become a family you know and so you
get new friends that way and you know
all kinds of ways and it becomes it
becomes your family here in Los Angeles
and I'm sure a lot of people have the
same feeling when they come to LA they
kind of start a new family in a way
because a lot of people come here not
knowing anybody one of the common themes
you've talked about is on things not
going as planned my sense is you like to
plan like to be organized I very much do
I don't understand I was helping a
friend recently plan a movie shoot and
he has all these things handwritten on a
paper I'm like all right well let's type
it out on the computer and get every
single location and the address on on a
on a page and every single actor and you
know every location we're gonna shoot
what time of day and said why are we
doing this and I'm like what do you mean
why are we doing this like you have all
the information in your brain but you're
gonna have a crew of you know 15 people
maybe more maybe less but these people
they have to know what you're thinking
and you can't always be the one telling
them it's very easy to hand all this
information so everybody already has it
all and when they forget it they just
look at the piece of paper you know you
have to save that time so no
everything's about organization with the
whole thing and you have to organize to
the last detail because when you get
there on the day it's not gonna go how
you planned and there's always problems
that arise with Wally got wasted there
was so many different problems that
arise I mean for one certain locations
we couldn't afford permits you know
certain places we had permits certain
places we didn't we got shut down one
day you know other days I'd convinced
security guards and police officers to
let us keep shooting you know and all
while he got wasted for starters I
convinced the crew from Teen Wolf the TV
show to come over on my movie so I was
like all the same people who had worked
together previously I'm the new guy
as the boss you know me so that was
really interesting dynamic but they want
nothing to do with cops or security
guards like if their union crew so if
they you know if they get any see a cop
or a security guy they're just stopped
working they don't want anything to do
with them they want no trouble no
nothing so it's on me to fix those
problems so I might be acting in the
scene and a security guard comes up and
I'm like finishing the take real quick
and then turn and take care of my my
problem over here and then hopefully
convince them and then come back and do
my take or direct or whatever I'm doing
at the time
so then the only place we got shut down
actually it was my apartment which is
the funniest thing ever there was one
day we got shut down in my apartment and
basically the this scene it's the iconic
scene in the movie actually the first
time they bring the body out in public
and it's a slow-motion scene and they're
walking with the body and actually if
you look at Patrick who plays Mitch in
the movie he looks left in the slow
motion scene and he's looking at a woman
who's screaming at us going where's your
permit I'm gonna shut you down and
that's why he's looking left but it's in
slow motion you barely you know you have
no idea what he's looking at he just
glances left that's what he's looking at
some woman screaming at us telling us
you know where's your permit and so I
managed to get that take done
and then I went up to the woman was like
hey I'm so sorry did somebody bother you
are we bothering you or how can I help
you she was like I want to see your
permit and I was like okay well I just
sent somebody to go get the permit so
why don't we just I'm gonna shoot one
more and then and then you know and then
I'm sure somebody be back to show you
the permit she's like I need to see now
I'm calling the cops and she has the
phone right there and I'm like okay I
try my best you know so I was like guys
were shutting it down everybody wanted
to kill her you know the crew they just
set up all these giant lights and
everything the cast and I was like don't
talk to her don't bother because I fully
know that we have to come back there
three days later at that date and shoot
with cops and fake guns and all he does
I can't have the cops be called now
Brewer how the heck am I gonna shoot
here in three days
so I'm like nowhere to speak to her just
leave her alone
and then one of my actors said to it it
was so funny while James Batson who
plays while he does a phenomenal job he
goes way to destroy art how many passes
there assists fi day today because we
were playing like a a silly comedy movie
but and then actually when we came back
there three days later she did end up
calling the cops and luckily she didn't
do in the daytime so there's a scene in
the movie where some dirty cops shoot
somebody and that was in the daytime and
luckily were between the two buildings
and no one called the cops because if a
cop came up and sauce with fake guns and
police uniforms they probably were to
shut us down but the cops didn't get
there till nighttime and we saw the cop
come and he posts up about I don't know
50 yards from my apartment on the street
just parks there and just watches and
luckily at that point we were shooting
all the SUV car scenes so we would we
brought this SUV between the two
buildings and we set up all the lights
on the hood pointing inward and the
cameras on attached to the hood of the
car and how are we gonna leave the cops
right there we can't drive around with
this stuff on there and nobody should do
that I'm not encouraging anyone to do
this at all you should get a tow truck
and not drive a car with lights pointing
at your face and a camera but we we had
to do it we had to do at that moment and
so basically I got out of the car I
turned off all the lights I turned off
the camera and luckily there's no
streetlight right outside of my
apartment so when we pulled out you
could only see the headlights of the car
and I turned laughed them away from the
cop and we would drive down the street
and then I'd get out and turn out all on
all the lights and turn on the camera
and then we would just drive slowly on
these residential roads and shoot the
scenes so or parking in a parking lot
and shoot the scenes if you couldn't see
out the windows so that's what we did
and then we'd come back after 3040
minutes of shooting and drive faster and
not past the cop but close enough that
he could see us but there was no
streetlights so he couldn't I I'm
assuming he couldn't see the camera on
the hood and the lights and we managed
to get away with the whole thing
so my luck coming into play once again
so and then other days you know like we
shot at a casino and we had no business
being at the casino we didn't have
permits but I'm showing up with a you
know three ton grip truck and and a crew
of 15-20 people they the nice part is
were so big that people assume we must
have permission to be there because
there's no way you would come and try to
shoot there without permission and we're
shooting at the parking lot of the
casino and the two security guards come
up and they're like it was like a scene
out of super bed they're like dude
where's your permit guys where's you you
guys have a permit you know and my
friend David Lee was helping with the
movie goes yeah we have a permit and
then they laugh and they go because if
you do it we don't give a shit haha and
they laughed and then they left they
didn't end up even looking at trying to
look at a permit so which again luck
came into play there and another place a
security the head of security came and
he came at the absolute wrong time they
were because we were running next to
something it was slightly dangerous what
we were doing and it should have never
been done in the first place but I was
looking at the footage focused on the
camera and the first ad was trying to
get more footage and she was she was
like yeah Ron run Ronald quit Louise in
the movie one of my actors plays a dirty
cop run next to that moving object you
know and he did and it's not really safe
to do that and then the head of security
comes up right as he's doing that it's
like the worst possible time he could
come and and he was like whoa whoa what
are you guys doing here like this is not
safe
you need a permit to be here and it took
like 20-30 minutes to talk to him and
convince them to let us stay there and
at the beginning he was totally against
it but I was like I saved up this is my
life savings like I saved up all my
money and this is I'm shooting a big
youtube video because the moment you say
a feature they assume you have money so
I just told them how much a youtube
video and you can't shut me down and it
and you just please please please and
eventually after 20 minutes of hearing
me sob and talk you know and be sweet
and nice because I was never mean you
know he said fine you can shoot but
don't don't shoot there shoot you know
you could shoot on the stairs which is
like doesn't make any sense to me
you could shoot on the stairs in the
parking lot well luckily and scheduling
I knew the hardest place would shoot
would be where most of the pedestrians
were so we shot that first and that's
what he said you couldn't shoot anymore
well I already had all the footage I
needed up there so and only one more
take I needed up there I figured we'd do
it last now that we got shut down and we
shot the stairs in the parking lot next
and so I scheduled just perfect knowing
that we had so much time and when to
show up with a crew that I showed up
with you usually have some time if you
start shooting right away before people
shut you down because they're wondering
what you're doing there and they don't
come up and shut you down right away and
I actually had a defense for that
because the crew sees a security guard
at a cop they immediately don't do
anything so I would have sometimes I
would just go up to a cop or security
guard and be like hey how you doing are
you having a good night yeah when do you
get off oh that's awesome
cool well have a great night you know
and I would just walk away I would just
make small talk and walk away and the
crew would see me talk to the security
guard or the cop and be like oh okay
he's squared everything we're we're good
when really in fact I just talked to him
about their day and and was friendly but
see after I'm friendly too they assume I
must be there because people that don't
they're not supposed to be whether they
stay shy away they act like they're
being sneaky no I just come up
completely confront you'd be super nice
and walk away so they were like how do
you know about this they'd a spy there's
so other security Isaac do you know does
the movie shooting here like well let's
call the boss you know like and they'd
call maybe their boss and they don't
know and then they call their boss well
meanwhile I already had an hour and a
half to shoot so I got some footage and
so that's a lot of part of the
scheduling is like you have to try to
think of those kind of problems and
solve them so yeah that was and
sometimes cops would just be like oh we
saw you're shooting a movie if I have a
lot of important equipment we're just
keeping an eye on you and they would
just watch us but I wasn't in Hollywood
I was in
Southbay so where I was in Pasadena or
somewhere where you know the cops if you
do it in Hollywood you probably are
gonna get shut down and some places you
definitely do get shut down I don't
encourage people not to have a permit
you know but we had to take the chance
because we just didn't have the money so
you know we go for it
there's a cave scene in the movie we go
to this gigantic we go to this gigantic
cave in the movie and the ending scene
is like in there's a big cave and so we
found that location it's a movie Ranch
like two hours north of Los Angeles and
they were building the cave when we went
there two months earlier and I was like
oh this is great they're like you know
what they do is they dig a hole in the
ground basically and so the walls of the
cave a real dirt but then they build the
top of the cave over with construction
and then you know do dry mold or
whatever make it look like dirt and then
they put lights in there so then you
have total control in the cave to make
it look the way you want so I went two
months earlier before shooting and paid
for the location and was like oh this is
great we're gonna be the first people
shooting in this giant beautiful cave
and I'm super excited about it well the
day before shooting before we're gonna
go up there they tell us basically that
the cave is not finished the half the
cave is finished and the other half is
not done at all so you know you can't
shoot here and I'm like we're coming to
shoot there we have a contract I can't
not go there now so I was like I said
Seth my set times my partner my writing
partner producing partner up there to
take pictures of it so I ended up having
to shoot the scene facing one direction
because you can't you have to face only
one direction in that scene so every
every shot in that whole scene is facing
one direction but you don't know so I'm
talking to you behind you is the same
wall that's behind me we just lit it
different and so that was the solution
to that problem is like we went up there
and I was like what am I gonna do I'm
gonna just have to shoot everything one
direction so I had to keep in my head
when people walk like what direction
they were and what direction we shot and
and like the wall differently so the
cracks because it's not a flat wall to
make it look different and it was really
hard for my DP and the people around me
to trust that I could do that in my head
you know but no one's ever mentioned it
no one has ever noticed that in that in
the movie so when you watch the movie
it's facing all one direction so yeah
which problems do you like figuring out
more which is which is a better
challenge for you
the problems that come up as a director
because most of them are out of your
control they're all external things or
as a screenwriter they're really
internal they're about you cracking the
story somehow I mean they're very
different the nice part about the
screenwriting process for me and Seth is
that we didn't have a time limit you
know we didn't have a you know some
people have to write scripts for pay and
they have a time limit they have to rush
through things we had enough time to
really figure out problems and also just
do rewrites after rewrite after a
rewrite to try to get it right and
sometimes you know like originally in
the original script in the movie while
he got wasted we have dirty cops chasing
us because spoiler alert Wally Wally
actually filmed them kill somebody so
then there's his phone so they're
chasing us the whole movie trying to get
his phone back because he tried to
blackmail them but he's dead the whole
time they don't know he's dead so
they're chasing us trying to get that
phone and and in the writing originally
those were mafia guys and it just didn't
really work in the writing process and I
think I just kind of obsessed that's one
of the reasons why it's hard for me to
start a project it's like once I'm in it
I'm obsessive and so I would obsess and
obsess obsess trying to fix the problem
and I think in a dream actually I came
up with them being dirty cops and then I
wake up in the morning and I like have
the solution and I was like 30 cops
perfect back when we wrote it now it's
like of course 30 cops they're
everywhere there's all this footage of
them killing people and all those kinds
of things back then we this is 2014 that
I think there was like one incident of a
cop shooting a guy so wasn't so
prevalent as it is now so it was kind of
like I came up with the perfect idea now
it's kind of not I guess obvious through
a lot of people of the biggest villains
would be dirty cops but back then it
wasn't like that
so I mean that's how it tie it all
together and I came up with the dirty
cops I also came up with the phone and
recording him because we needed we
needed to move the story forward and
having people chase us and it was
figuring out how do we do that
we have somebody chase us and why are
they chasing us and all that kind of
stuff and so I came up with dirty cops
were filmed doing a dirty deed and
they're chasing us to get the evidence
that was that was like the one of the
key elements of writing it it was like
okay this can move the story forward so
but the problem is onset totally
different because a very time restraint
you know it's like we're going and we're
shooting no matter what I can't stop
this train so if a cave isn't finished
we have to fix it if the grip truck gets
a flat tire with our grip truck got a
flat tire one day it was like well what
can we shoot without the lights because
we don't have lights right now you know
so there's just all these kinds of
problems you know that come up on the
day and you just have to fix them and
you can't there's no time as a film
director like I'm asking I'm answering
questions every single second of the day
as a director I'm also I was also acting
in the film so I got to focus on my
lines and delivery and all that stuff
and and helping actors but I'm still
answering questions do you want this do
you want to wear this do you want her to
wear this blouse or this blouse what
color do you want oh I want that one
do you like the lighting over here is
this too dark to light I'm getting asked
a question almost every 60 seconds so
you have to be fast when you ask me my
questions I don't have time for you to
give me a song and a dance about why
something's wrong just tell me what's
wrong so we can fix it and I try not to
ever turn down ideas that people want to
give ideas I just usually tell them okay
I have a plan for this so I'm gonna do
what I planned and we're gonna get to
that afterwards and if I don't like it
we're not going to get to it but I don't
have to tell you that you know I'll just
say we ran out of time but I don't want
to ever turn any ideas down because
that's the moment people stop giving me
ideas and it needs to be a creative
space for people to share ideas you know
and and speak their mind and do it in an
appropriate way though because I do have
a limited time and I am doing
certain things so if you're the there's
a certain time to give me an idea most
of it hopefully in pre-production
I have table reads I have you know I try
to get people together so they can be
part of the creative process so when we
get on set you're not like oh I have an
idea I've been wanting to tell you know
you should have done that when we were
rehearsing you know I mean that's why I
do all that time and I go to every
single location with the DP and tell
them every shot that I want to do and
the look that I want and as much as you
can do ahead of time it really helps you
when you're making the movie because the
unforeseeable problems come up and if
you haven't discussed the things you can
discuss ahead of time you might not get
a chance to discuss them anymore you
know as to where you could have settled
that out and pre-production on how it's
gonna get lit or you know I have a shot
list I know all my shots I know how
we're gonna put it together in my head
when we get there and sometimes there's
only one way when you go to editing to
put it together and when I edit the film
I edit with an editor but I'm there
every single day every single frame
every cut is usually me going no don't
go back a millisecond you know because
he hands it to him here and I needed his
hand out like I know exactly where I
want to cut usually and I hear some
directors actually edit in camera I mean
it's so they hype that up I'm just like
it's so not important nowadays it's just
funny it doesn't matter he if he cut it
yeah you don't have to cut it you might
as well film for twenty more seconds
you're not paying for film but anyways
it's another topic with while he got
wasted it sounds like it was it was a
fun project with you and Seth and there
were no time constraints in the writing
have you had a screenwriting project
where there was time constraint and what
happened I've been lucky I haven't had a
script that well no that's not true at
are actually three guys on a couch you
know we raised the money and so I had a
month I had a month to write that script
actually so no very much I've had two
time restraint it's just really really
obsessing over it and really trying to
get it good and three guys on a couch is
about three guys running out their couch
and
mm-hmm and I had two story lines the one
guy woke up and he has a girl that he
thinks he slept with in his room but he
doesn't really remember anything because
he drank too much and he's trying to
figure out like what this woman is doing
there but as soon as he slept with her
and she's cleaning and she's doing all
this stuff he's like man she's like the
best woman I've ever met like she's
cleaning the bathroom after I've only
slept with her once so he's trying to
figure that out and she keeps appearing
like she leaves the apartment is like
okay cool I'll never see her again
he comes home and she's cooking what are
you doing in my apartment
oh I'm just cooking us food you know and
I cleaned this and that he's going home
man Wow who is this woman but okay he's
clueless at the same time we're doing
couch interviews trying to fill the
couch to make rent because we don't have
enough money for rent so I was in the
writing process I was like how do I
connect these two stories and just
obsessing over it obsessing over because
they need to be connected for it to be
good and so I eventually figured out
okay this woman that he woke up and is
there he rented the couch out last night
to this woman and he doesn't remember so
they already have filled the couch the
whole episode but they don't realize it
so that's other two storylines had tied
together and so then I was like oh wow
that makes a lot of fun dialogue where
she's talking about renting the place
and he's talking about sex and they're
totally on two different pages and so
he's very confused by her answers to
certain things because he's totally
talking about something totally
different so the writing restraints of
that was just I mean it has to be
there's in my brain there's only one
good enough and so it's trying to meet
that bar and when you have a time
restraint it's even more obsessive and
you got to X out other things in your
life at the moment I can't pick up my
phone or I can't do anything other than
this so it's pure concentration what
happened with that project we shot it we
ended up shooting three guys in a couch
that was three guys in the couch it's on
Amazon Prime you can watch on Amazon
Prime just like parole officers and I
Amazon Prime as well for free and while
he's on Amazon for a purchase at the
moment and Durant but did someone else
want you to come in and and make that
project or how did that work
with it was kind of like the wheels were
already turning on three guys in a couch
it was like we had a date already to
shoot it and so that's the thing about
raising money for any project people
didn't tell you they have money but they
don't have money forever money just
doesn't sit in someone's bank account
and that waiting for you to get around
to it so we raised the money to shoot a
TV pilot and those people that had that
money I didn't want it to go away so we
already had shooting dates I didn't want
to go hey listen we're gonna shoot in
January February March whatever when it
was December or whatever so I I knew
that I wanted to stick to those dates
and it was my first time ever shooting
anything so it was like all guns blazing
let's do this you know I didn't want to
take any chances and since then too I've
learned that lesson over and over again
you know someone comes up to me and goes
hey I have this money I really want to
do a movie and I'm like I don't have a
project yet that I want to do I'm not
sure kind of stinks in a way cause it's
like man I wish I had that paperwork in
order and the project that I want to do
so I can take your money but I can't
take your money if I don't know what I
want to do with it yet you know so
that's happened in at least two or three
times in my career where somebody has a
certain dollar amount they're like okay
I'd love to do something with you and I
don't have the project ready yet
you know and that's a tough part with
having not wanting to ever shoot
anything that I'm not passionate about
you know that's the problem with that
because if I'm not passionate about it
I'm not going to shoot it I don't want
to do it so your decision to be behind
the camera as well I mean did you always
want to just be in front of the camera
or that was just never part of the big
goal the big goal was just to make as
many movies as you could I started out
as an actor actually so I grew up
studying acting I would study
performances like Brando on the
waterfront and and you know all the ones
I could watch you know my father and me
shared that back when I was a kid
showing me performances and talking
about acting and I always wanted to be
an actor and I'd actually I I tried out
for a play when I was in sixth grade and
I didn't get it apart my sister got the
part in it and then I had extreme stage
fright when it came to auditioning and
then I auditioned for a play I think
when I was a sophomore in high school
and I didn't get it either and then I
eventually auditioned for a play again
when I was a junior in high school and
she took a chance on me because my
auditioning skills weren't that great
and I got the play and once I finally
did it I kind of sword they ended up
naming an award after me my first year
acting in the high school and they
handed out every year now called the a
Ward award back at my little high school
glide high school and and then the next
following year I got Best Actor you know
and I was competing against all these
guys that were acting since they were
freshmen and I just kind of came in and
did my thing but we would sell out every
night you know which was really cool 300
seater and most people I can say most
people one of the comments of the
director she would do a speech to all
the actors and she came back one was
still one of the best comments I've ever
gotten compliments I've gotten in my
career she gave her the speech to all
the actors and then everybody left and
she said Adam just do what you do you
know because a lot of people were out
there just to see you and it was fun it
was fun times we were doing comedies and
I felt like I get out of them eating out
of my hand you know just making them
laugh and stuff and comedy always came
natural to me it's one of the reasons
why I've made comedy films now and I
think I've started I always wanted to
direct to of course but it started with
a love for acting and then I think I
started I went to directing sooner than
later because I realized that the
auditions I were getting and weren't
good enough to get to where I wanted to
be so a lot of the directing I do now is
motivated by my acting in it and right
now I'm actually hired to write a script
and direct a movie which I might not end
up acting in but I do love directing but
I think a lot of my movies will be
because I want to play this character so
I will then direct it and you know they
kind of feed each other
motivations as a director and as an
actor so sorry have you already written
the script I'm writing the script now
it's about a book called catch the white
tiger it's a book that came out and the
guy who wrote the book tonio Sally
wanted me really to do a movie and I
said well I can't make a movie without
script so then he hired me to write a
script and ultimately wants to hire me
to direct the movie - which I think will
be made in the next couple years I you
know I I don't have a time restraint on
it I just it's when it's right you know
we want to make a movie that's it's
gonna be a biopic drama movie so it's
gonna be a lot bigger than then Wally
and we're gonna go from the 60s 70s 80s
and so I mean it's it's gonna have a lot
a lot of work and I think it's gonna be
gonna shoot in Beirut and as well as in
the United States so it's gonna be a
huge undertaking and part of that is by
not rushing and and first it's making
the script what it needs to be because
it could go in a lot of different
directions you know you have a lot of
different morals and themes in a movie
you know it could be inspiring or it
could be a drama and a downer I mean you
can make it in so many different
directions on what you want to do so we
have to make those choices and figure
out what's the he has a 400 page book I
have to make into a 120 page script or
whatever and what parts of his life do I
leave out what parts of his life are
important for the story that we want to
tell so it's it's it's a very
interesting process that I'm just
starting - we're starting the outline
now and try to figure that stuff out
it's such a trick with biopics because
when they're done right it's amazing and
then sometimes when they're when they're
rushed I know there's been certain ones
and I won't say which ones but I wanted
so much for them to be good but that was
so rushed and later we're trying and I
saw and then there's others that I don't
know where the magic is and that but
it's just done in such a way where you
could just you know you you feel like
you are living that life and so there's
a real I think my favorite bio pics are
the
ones that you really get to know the
character and the motivations of what
motivated him to do certain things I
feel like a lot of the biopics nowadays
they kind of get away with just telling
you the facts and I kind of I feel like
it's a cop-out in a way I'm like what
motivated this person what to do the
amazing things they did or terrible
things that they did what motivated them
that's what interests me as a film
viewer you know so hopefully we can
achieve those kinds of things which are
an easy a lot of people they don't know
what motivates them you know but as
sometimes as an outsider you can see it
so we'll see you know I hope it's a very
three-dimensional movie in that that
it's a character piece as well as
telling the facts of what happened in
his life so when you were a script
reader did you have any biopics come on
to you I don't believe so I don't
believe I ever read a biopic and that
was very much in the 2000s biopics
winter like there and like now like
everybody wants to do biopics which is
funny I didn't see myself doing a biopic
at all actually I I there's a movie I
wrote already it's already written
called attachment theory and I saw me
shooting that next it's about a guy a
low-end mob guy who basically works for
his uncle and he collects money for
people that owe money to his uncle who
works for the cartel but he's very much
like his uncle shields him from doing
anything really bad so he just kind of
beats people up a little bit that was
the money it's kind of like a Rocky
character and but he needs money because
his dad's needs a surgery and can't
really walk so he's desperate need for
money so I had a meeting with his uncle
and some of the heads of the cartel
basically he speaks out of turn because
they need a guy to do a job and he's
like I'll do the job not knowing what
the job is
so they hand him an address and he goes
to East LA to to do this job he doesn't
even know what he's doing he goes in
this abandoned house and they've
kidnapped a woman and he has to watch
the woman for three days basically and
he watches the woman in this abandoned
house and he ends up falling in love
with the girl and the problem is the
kidnapping goes bad they're gonna come
back and kill her so he has to make a
choice either to save this woman's life
and take
on you know the cartel and everybody
that he knows or to kill the woman and
so of course he he saves her and
everything starts going crazy from there
but it's already written I already have
it written and I want to shoot it and I
will shoot it eventually I wrote it for
me - also to play that guy so but that's
it's called attachment theory right now
but I have no idea what it eventually be
called because I'm not completely sold
on that name but that's the movie and
I'll get around to making that
eventually - would you recommend that
most actors learn screenwriting
I think it's an actor I think it's
important for you to learn as much as
you possibly can the more you can learn
behind the camera stuff - it will help
you you know and it's the same thing
with directors actually um I hear so
many directors saying they were
terrified of actors and I think to
myself what's wrong with you taking
acting classes start learning about that
craft because clearly you need to if
they scare you and I think it's the same
for actors though if you direct things
if you know about things as an actor now
that I'm a filmmaker I mean if we were
shooting this and I didn't like the way
I deliver that line I would just say it
again and then you could cut out the
first one I don't even need to tell you
to cut you know and so there's all these
tricks you can learn as a director like
there's a lot of very talented actors
that I work with that they don't
understand that I can stop you wherever
I want to stop you if you stutter if you
make it and point you know and change
the angle on somebody else for a split
second and come back to you like you
don't have to have an amazing take all
the way through it means nothing to me
whether you killed it all the way
through as long as you killed it if you
killed the first half of the take one
time and completely bombed it the second
half and then we do a second take and
you bomb the first half and then you
kill it the second half I'm good that's
all I need so that's the thing to you as
an actor you should never cut yourself
because maybe you did screw up but I
don't care and neither does anybody else
because we're making films now we're not
making theatre so we don't need you to
do it good all the way through and so it
there is an element that you should be
learning as
some director about acting as an actor
about the film directing and about
lighting and about everything else you
should know you should know what lens
they're putting on cuz you got to know
your box you know is it a 50 millimeter
lens is it a 200 millimeter line like
what is the what is the frame so what I
can do in the frame you know because if
it's an extreme closeup to there if
you're dealing with the correct you know
move top-of-the-line cameras your depth
of field is only so far so if I move
forward like this I'm not a focus if I
move back I'm in focus these are all
things you need to know but a lot of
that's why experience comes into play
because most actors learn from
experience things like you don't learn
how to be on a camera in an acting class
usually you know because what acting
class has the lenses and has depth of
field and and all these can edit the
scene together you know you don't learn
that stuff so you have to learn it as
you go as you as you perform your craft
and movies and TV and that kind of stuff
itself as an actor have you ever sensed
that a director was fearful of you or
intimidated you know I don't know I
haven't but maybe I was naive because
when you're an actor you're very focused
on what you're doing you know what I
mean sometimes I've done in there was
one film I did it where I had a
six-minute take you know and I didn't
there's no cutting you know he didn't
have the time to cut so he shot me all
in one angle for six minutes that's six
minutes of dialogue where I have to know
every word on that page and I want to
kill it and kick ass and hit all the
moments that I've picked out in
decisions I've picked out for that
character and how he feels about this
line of that line it's a lot of focus
you know and especially and when Wally
got wasted I'm not really doing so much
of a character piece it's not far from
it's not too hard for me to play that
character so I'm not juggling a lot of
hats but when you're you these Academy
award-winning actors they have an accent
they have a limp they have their face
only moves in a certain way when they
talk you know so it's every single one
of those things takes focus and
concentration and so
to worry about whether an actor's fear
for view is probably the last thing on
their brain they're too focused on their
performance and what's going on with
them they're you know they're there if
any other energy is on somebody else
it's on their other actor because that's
who's feeding them in the scene you know
if you don't react to something in there
on camera then now you're not giving a
good performance you're not listening
correctly and listening if someone else
is on camera with you listening is so
important and a lot of acting classes
they teach all you need to listen but
that's not necessarily true either
because you might be acting with a
square or a checkmark on a wall and the
other actor might not even be there you
know a lot of times in wall-e I didn't
have time to I didn't have time to let
somebody act with me we had so much time
restraint sometimes I would give the
actor acting with me a lot more time and
then I would give the actor with me a
lot more time and then when it was my
turn to act I would just okay I'll do it
by myself
I just need the script supervisor give
me my eyeline I picked my my line okay
this is my eyeline I'm just gonna act
the whole scene like this and talk to
them like they're there and then they're
not there and then the scripture
provider is gonna give me the other line
as fast as he can deliver it and then
I'm gonna do mine the next line so we
can speed up the whole process and if I
don't like the way I live deliver my
line I'm just gonna deliver it again and
we're just gonna get through it as fast
as possible which is upsetting in a way
because you don't really give your best
acting performance but I'm the director
first
I'm an actor second in a way and
eventually hopefully as I get better and
better I can take on more character
pieces that are harder on acting but I
laugh at some people like you're acting
so good because I think to myself god
I'm cutting myself so short on these
sometimes give myself one take you know
for you to compliment my acting is
extremely flattering in a way because I
can't wait to show people what I really
what kind of chops I have when I really
start bite off something you know that
you can't see me as and then if I prove
that that's a that's the motivation of
an actor is to try to do something that
you can't see them doing and but then
convince you that they're really that
person that's the fun
part of being an actor so in my opinion
so how do you think making while I got
wasted helped you to move forward I
think so while I got ways is my first
feature so to be moving forward on after
it how does it help me move forward I
think it's it's it's kind of amazing and
I try to explain this to people but
until you've done a feature people don't
believe you can do a feature because so
many people have failed doing a feature
so just a lot more doors open up in a
way you know people know that you've
done it and if it's at least half-decent
they think you can do it again you know
and actually I think I've read something
that 99% of filmmakers make their first
feature they never make a feature again
so that's how many people try to do this
and go I don't want to do that again
this is horrible you know because you
have to really love thumb that want to
do it because it is so hard you know
like I said earlier it's like two three
hours a night I slept on Wally
and how many emergencies that would
happen or whatever and everything's
comes back on me so if you don't like to
be a leader you're not gonna like being
a film director you know you have to
manage egos you have to manage you have
to keep your cool under all
circumstances and at the same time make
the right decisions you don't want to
put anybody in danger you don't want to
you know your movies important but we're
making a movie we're not curing cancer
so let's not endanger anybody or do
anything that's unsafe and after you've
done your first feature it's just a
totally different respect you get from
people and opportunities open up way
more because now you're a real filmmaker
really I mean everybody kind of looks at
you like an amateur when you're making
short films but after you made a feature
you you're in the pros
I mean you are you're competing once you
make a feature you're competing with the
Avengers you're competing with all these
other movies there's no scale of like oh
that movie
no you're competing with them all
because the audience on Amazon can
choose Avengers that they can choose
while I got wasted you know so you're
competing with everybody
and that's why I take it easy on myself
because you know I didn't have five
hundred million dollars to make a movie
if we had 70 grand so the fact that I'm
even competing with these movies and
some people are watching my movie I'm
thrilled because there's so much content
out there right now to watch so but you
learn you know you learn and
opportunities they just open up they
open up and you don't know where they're
gonna come from after you've done your
first feature so you just got to do it
you got to do it you gotta take the
chance you got to learn you got to fall
in your face and you got to go do it
even if it never sees the light of day
at least you did it and do it again
when did you read your first
screenwriting book in which which book
oh my first one I think my first one was
actually save the cat which is a really
good book and it was about outlining if
anybody wants to be a filmmaker I would
suggest that book save the cat if you
want to be a filmmaker it lays out
structure really well and now everything
doesn't have to be formulaic but
everything's almost been done at this
point so I mean even when I'm making the
movie now where I'm making a okay this
movie about the book catches the white
tiger it's about it's a biopic so I go
and I watch all biopics and what what
kind of biopic do want to make wolf of
Wall Street is very different than the
founder you know I mean so the
blueprints there in a way you know so
that helps you make a blueprint that
book and but I feel like books were
helpful that's a very helpful book but I
felt like watching movies was the most
helpful for me you know like my brother
who's my writing partner will send me
scripts and be like here you know he
just sent me like three scripts
yesterday of all these biopics I'd
rather watch the movies because I'm very
much I know that a script can change so
much and compared to making the movie
and so when you're seeing it in the
movie it might be an improv it might
would be whatever but that could still
be a script even maybe it wasn't a
script it could have been a script if
you would have wrote it that way so I
kind of like watching the final product
more than
reading the script in the sense of
learning when it comes to like
Goodfellas reading the script or
watching the movie I'd rather watch the
movie and analyze that then actually
read the script but my brother is the
opposite so it just depends on what how
you learned and you can get your hands
nowadays with the internet you get your
hands on so many scripts and so many
things and learn so much you can read
the script for Goodfellas you know when
I was a when I was young the kid you
know you could never get your hands on a
script like that unless you went to it
like American film institution or one of
these big film schools that have those
kind of scripts then you could read it
and learn from it but nowadays I mean
people can learn so easily with the
internet it's just it's a great thing if
you want to learn what three scripts did
he send you
ah he sent me wolf of wallstreet I think
he sent me founders and he sent me
Goodfellas that's why I brought him all
up so I think I opened wolf of
wallstreet and read the first couple of
pages and I was like I don't know watch
the movie but I don't know if I'll read
it or not I know he's read it but he's
my writing partner so you know I would
like to read him just for fun but I feel
like now's the time that really for me I
get more from a movie than a script
because I'm a filmmaker
he's a script writer so you know he's
more of a script like he wants to just
be a script writer when I brother
Charlie Ward me I want to be a filmmaker
and an actor I don't really I write
scripts out of necessity I don't really
want to write scripts it's like I write
them because I don't have a script you
know and I've been blessed with the fact
that at least I know structure well and
I get I've watched god I used to watch
two three movies I used to watch two
three movies a day when I was a kid you
know we moved I moved from Philadelphia
when I was a kid to Roseburg glide
Oregon when I was 12 years old and there
was nothing to do I went from the mall
and the skating rink to like okay
there's a lot of trees around there's
nothing to do the first neighbors like a
mile away well I would just watch movies
like crazy you know so I'd watch two
three movies a day half the time all my
free time was spent watching movies or
outside running around
and they I've heard it before you gotta
watch 10 you got to spend ten thousand
hours on your craft to really be a
master at it
well I've easily watched you know over
ten thousand hours of movies to gotten
to where I've gotten and honestly that's
what makes you an artist in a way
because if you have the things that used
to shock me and impress me and intrigue
me when I was a kid watching movies are
different than what they do now because
I've seen so many of them so it's
different you know you can think back to
the time of when it did but ultimately
now I have so much more of a library in
my head of movies that now you're
competing with all those as to where if
I only saw seven movies this movie's
amazing but it's only competing with six
but if you watch 10,000 hours or
whatever now I've seen Godfather and the
Goodfellas in there they're both mafia
movies now they're competing against
each other and so some people nowadays
that they say oh I I this is my favorite
movie but they've never seen all these
movies in the 70s and 80s and I'm
thinking well yeah but you don't really
you don't know your craft
I mean you know you haven't spent the
time to watch all those movies and and
really learn your craft you know would
you say Charlie's good at one part of
screenwriting and you're good at the
other or I mean like how do you work
together with a partner how is that um
with Seth it was different so Seth Himes
and me wrote while he got wasted Charlie
is writing this new movie with me two
very different writing partners for me
so Seth really wanted to put the words
on the page and so I would basically do
the outline and then he would go off and
write by himself and then come bring it
back to me and then I'd read it make all
these corrections on the page and be
like the scene doesn't hit this moment
it does I need this moment and this is
like like as an example this is the low
of the movie like these guys have to
turn on each other I need a good
monologue here of him turn
on him and no hope you know and that was
one of the scenes that Seth couldn't end
up doing on his own but most of them I'd
give him notes and then he would go and
make funny moments and do certain things
and he would change it and write it and
then like the lo of the movie and while
he got wasted there on a cliffside
overlooking all of Los Angeles he could
never get that scene so I was like okay
I'll write it so then I wrote that scene
and the jokes in it are mine but the
jokes and the other scenes are his and
so we it's nice to write in a group
attached from a theory I wrote on my own
by myself but while he got wasted was
with Seth and then there's new ones with
my brother and my brother my brother and
me Ben range scrim since I was scripts
since I was a child so we have very much
shorthand with each other of like
thinking a lot of the same things and
stuff like that but he as well doesn't
it's funny I have not found anybody that
we'd like to write page words on the
page together it's kind of like he goes
off and writes I go off and write and we
come together it's I I've yet to find
somebody that likes to write in the room
together but that would be interesting
it would be a dream come true in a way
it'd be fun and I've done that with my
brother but parole officers we did
together but I acted out all the
characters in the living room and he sat
there and would type so I'm like living
the characters and saying what they
would say and then he's like writing
them down so it's a very different
process with parole officers on that but
most of them had people want to write
alone you know they want their
creativity to you know quiet and all
that kind of stuff so I was just
different
I just feel like the scale of movies
back in the 70s and 80s are very
different a lot of it has to do too with
the studio's not wanting to take chances
so much nowadays they back in the day
they would give you know a kid that did
some impressive short film a whole
budget you know for a movie and he would
get creative and do something but the
then they weren't so hands-on and I feel
like there are now but movies back in
the 70s and 80s they would do biopics
that were three hours three and a half
hours four hours it doesn't exist
anymore you know as to where when you
sat down and watch the biopic back in
the day and it was three and a half
hours long you felt like you lived a
whole life you know as the way a biopic
in an hour and 40 minutes I'm like huh
you know I didn't I didn't feel like I
really got to know the character you
know as to where in a biopic if you see
him and a lot of is where they start
compared to where they end and that very
much interests you it's like maybe they
start I remember Steven Spielberg's
talking about some movie where a guy
starts in the beginning the movie and he
has I think it's Lawrence of Arabia he
starts in the beginning and he has this
beautiful sword and his beautiful outfit
and he's so primped and proper and and
it's so clean and by the end of the
movie he's so bloody and his image of
the world has completely changed and
he's a mess and that's from start to
finish
ideally that's such a change in
character you know and bio biopic should
be character pieces I like in our movie
the one I'm chewing I don't know the
name of it yet but the book is called
catch the white tiger he's he starts the
movie he's selling in Lebanon he's
selling jeans American jeans in Lebanon
by the end he's selling Lebanese food to
Americans in America so I mean like that
full circle is very interesting to me
you know and also he's a kid in the
beginning and he's in a grown adult at
the end but we're figuring out it all
the the elements of that that
gonna put into it but but my original
point was just that biopic films back in
the day were such more epic 70s movies
80 there's way more epic and had way
more freedom to make a movie that was
longer than your typical below two hours
and a lot of it is because I feel like
today's society is so I remember I was
on a plane flight and I was watching a
woman she was doing her homework
movie was playing on on her laptop and
she was on her phone doing social media
all at the same time and I'm like but
don't you want to pause the movie I was
like I said excuse me are you watching a
movie right now she says yeah yeah I'm
watching a movie I said it's the first
time you've ever watched it she said
yeah it's the first time first time
watching a movie and she's doing her
homework and doing social media at the
same time at the movies playing I'm like
what's the point of watching a movie but
that's what that's the kind of world we
grew up and now everybody's attention
span is even shorter you know so it's
very interesting in that way you know
people I think my brother told me some
film students he was sitting next to and
they were like ah I saw The Godfather I
don't really see what the big point is
it wasn't very good you know it's
because their attention spans are so
short which sad in a way because like
how he's supposed to feel a movie unless
you really get into it you know like
Silkwood sorry to interrupt but I don't
know if you saw that I remember seeing
that as okay yeah it's pretty intense
you have all kinds of movies you just
bring it over that I haven't seen what
actors oh think is it Meryl Streep and
Cher I want to say sorry if it's wrong I
know someone's gonna write a call it's
definitely someone I sounds like a movie
I'd like to watch it's it's it's intense
and it's not necessarily a happy ending
but it's about a whistleblower at a
company and it's some really moved on
whistleblower company have I seen it I
don't know trying to Rack my brain
10,000 hours if I spend more time
watching yeah but I have to check it out
you know what I really love to do
actually I used to love to do this all
the time is taken actor I'd go on IMDB
and then I'd watched their movie history
in order
of every acting role they ever did and
nowadays it's way easier than back when
I was a kid you know I'd have to go to
the library or whatever and luckily
Netflix was around at a certain point
and you could just go to their library
that's such a big library but I loved
watching how they progressed as an actor
and I liked doing it for film directors
too and watching from starting movie to
the next movie and seeing how much they
learned and how they progressed as a
filmmaker as well as an actor yeah I
think I remember having to go to
Blockbuster to and they had this like
huge book there's almost like a
dictionary and you'd have to like go
through it and then try to like
cross-reference stuff and yeah that was
my first job my first job was at
Blockbuster which one the one in Oregon
yeah what an Oregon yeah and you'd have
your top picks or whatever and so my
first I was at Blockbuster and I would
literally like I loved helping people
discover new movies you know it's like a
joy to me back then and you used to get
the movies before they came down you
know before normal people got him that
was thrilling for a week and then also
you I remember I could rent five movies
a week and so that was like a one-way I
could you know watch so many movies it
was great so right I always liked the
movies at Blockbuster that there weren't
50 of them on the wall it was always
these obscure ones and it was a treasure
it was it was really a challenge to try
to hunt through and find them you know
so it wasn't necessarily yeah that's
gone now it's it's funny I missed that I
did too
I still stand it's funny because I'll
stand there people that know me well
I'll stand on the remote on Netflix or
whatever and I just like to look and I
spent 30 minutes looking and you know
people like what we ever we gonna watch
anything I just like to look I missed
that process at Blockbuster just looking
for movies you know and trying to find
something new is is very fun for me so I
don't know yeah I missed that too for a
while I got wasted how did you post
casting notices was it on the major
sites or before I even get into that
there was one thing I forgot to say
earlier Tom because I was talking
earlier about my you know believing in
yourself and all that kind of stuff my
dad was a very much a believer and
telling me I can do anything that I want
to do in life
actually he he wrote a book and he has a
child's book that's for sales called a
little bedtime journey and I think he
can go to a little bedtime journey calm
to get the book but it's an empowering
hypnotherapist book for children
actually where you like count down from
10 and it really makes them believe in
themselves and he used to actually read
that book to me all the time when I was
a child so just to plug that for him and
he's such as you know everything that I
am is because of him and my mother you
know for supporting me but so I had to
plug that but also the casting process
for a while I got wasted so I ended up
casting the whole movie myself we hired
we talked to more than one casting
director actually and we had these big
casting directors that were gonna help
cast the movie and they loved the script
they casted blackish the TV show and a
whole bunch of other TV shows they
casted and they loved the script which
was it's always nice to hear people in
the industry high up go hey who wrote
this script that's so good you know that
was great to hear but ultimately their
agent talking about of doing it so the
casting directors agent like who are
they no they're nobody special you know
so we ended up losing them eventually
because they had to focus on casting
shows and making more money than we were
gonna pay him so then we ended up
getting a casting director out of New
York and had her go after names
ultimately you haven't made a feature
yet you know I mean me I haven't made a
feature yet you're nobody special so
names
you got him Wow them with money we
didn't have mountain money so they're
not dead probably didn't even read the
script so I just like oh please read the
script you'll love it they by never did
so ultimately I ended up casting the
whole movie by luckily I've been here
long enough that I asked like the
producers owners and black the this
producer here this director there hey
can you suggest people and I'd give them
the breakdown and they'd send over 10 20
people in an email a lot nice enough to
send over 10 20 people who they thought
would be good for the role and I did
that and I asked acting schools and just
I mean searched high and low and had
every single person do video auditions
and so it was interesting because I
I didn't do in-person ones I would do
the video ones and then I would maybe
they are auditioned and they did decent
but they didn't do that great or did
what I want so then I'd call them and
give them coach them on how to do it
better and then let them do it again and
so that's how pretty much it took place
but Patrick our lead Patrick Kavanagh I
saw him in a play that Alec so a common
friend of ours put on and I saw him do a
play like six seven years before we even
shot wall-e oh and I just never forgot
him he was just very talented in the
play and he had a likability that I knew
was very charming and it was I thought
very Michael J Fox ish now I don't know
that he's that in the film because we
haven't playing such a neurotic but he
has that quality has a very likable
quality and so I wanted him to do it but
then we were going after names and he
was like okay and I kept telling him
please audition do an audition tape for
me and he said he would but he never got
around to it and I auditioned like 3040
people and then eventually he did it and
he nailed it and then we didn't you know
it was no question after his tape that
this was the guy that needed to do the
pardon I think Patrick did such a great
job in the movie I'm really proud of his
performance and then he's the the lead
in the movie and I'm his counterpart and
then the third lead is Erin Groban who
plays Geri in the movie and he's very
much the iconic stoner character that's
not that smart
and constantly doing the wrong things
you know at one point we get finally get
rid of the body and he left his wallet
in the pocket you know so there's like
all these kinds of things and why did
you leave the wallet in the pocket oh I
don't like my wallet in my pocket it
gets all crunchy you know like just
stupid stuff happen with him and that's
very much a character that's iconic in
history I mean Jack Black played in an
Orange County and Sean Penn plated in
was that high school movie Ridgemont
High yeah and so Erin did a great job
and actually Erin did like a commercial
for Seth my partner when he was working
for a company but Erin axe and
everything he possibly can he's just a
working actor and he doesn't care what
it is and you know just going to act and
so he had worked with him and like a
just uh not even him like a real acting
job it was like talking to the camera I
believe and he's like well I know this
guy he might work and he had a big beard
at the time and I mean he did an
audition tape there was moments where I
saw that it could work and so we found
him eventually - and it was so hard to
find that role who's the hardest five
one of the hardest roles for me to cast
because people acting stoned
is it's just a very hard thing for
people to do like everybody I believe
their acting I don't believe that really
that person and so you got to find that
person that you believe they're not that
smarter you believe that they're perma
high basically so that was a hard thing
to do but he did I think you did a great
job some people I find that people
either love or they hate him
they're either talking about how great
he did or they're like I really believe
that so it's very much a love or hate
role but that's any role in history so
it's oh it's okay Melissa our leading
lady that was hard to find - because I
was trying to find somebody who had that
kind of Cameron Diaz in the mask quality
or Dumb and Dumber quality that was very
much laughy and fun and never took
anybody too serious and it was really
hard to find actresses to do that
because the lines they would always read
and it came off either a little bitchy
or a little snobby or a little something
that I just didn't like and Lissa
actually lives in Nashville she doesn't
live in LA and somebody suggested her
for the movie and then I reached out to
her and I was like hey would you others
for the movie she said yeah but I live
in Nashville you'd have to fly me out
for the movie and so I was like oh gosh
and then ever you know the budget for
that and and I was like fine you know
what you could just read for it you know
did you make an audition tape and I'm
thinking she'll probably bomb and then
we don't have to talk about the details
later and of course you did the audition
tape but she absolutely killed it and
and then I was like gosh shucks sorry I
found my I found my Lucy so we ended up
flying her out to do the part and stuff
and then we had a lot we had a lot of
luck too with some amazing actors Alex
soul who was in
American history acts and he's in all
kinds of movies back in the day he came
out of retirement for the movie and
acted in the movie he kicks ass and a
very iconic Russian Roulette scene that
people seem to love Larry Hanken came
out for the movie and he's I mean he's
an icon in my opinion and how many great
movies he's done from Escape from
Alcatraz with Clint Eastwood you know I
mean he's been around so long and he
acts in so many things I managed to get
him in the movie and he did a great job
we had Sally Kirkland in the movie who
won I mean she's won a Golden Globe
she's got nominated for Academy Award
she came out and acted for us so I was
just really lucky with my cast and I'm
sure I'm forgetting people that were
phenomenal in the cast as well but I was
just really lucky that I found the right
people for the roles that we did and I
pride myself on having good actors in
the movie because we have to discover
talent you know because we don't have
enough money to get a name or somebody
who's well known so I literally had to
find people that were undervalued on
both sides in front of the camera and
behind the camera you have to find
people that are undervalued for their
skill at this moment in this time
because all the same people I pie
couldn't afford to hire now a couple
years later because now they are getting
paid more to do behind the camera work
and in front of the camera work so do
you have an interesting story about LAX
I'll get to that rewind real quick
because if you want celebrity stories
Alex soles part in the movie that his
iconic role on the Russian Roulette
scene was actually written for JK
Simmons oh well I met JK Simmons one of
the small jobs I had I was inspecting
Tesla's and yes and the company knew was
JK Simmons just one of the Academy Award
at the time and so they're like we know
you're the movie guy and so I was like
their number one person that go do this
kind of stuff and so I went and
inspected his Tesla and it was like I
saw whiplash like two days before and I
was like man I gotta I gotta take
advantage this opportunity I didn't know
how I was gonna take advantage of it but
I was like okay cool I'm gonna try to
strike up a conversation and really try
connect with this person because that's
the that's and that's a word of advice
for people to like when you meet a
celebrity or somebody that has clout try
to befriend them try to talk to them as
a human being don't try to get a photo
don't try to even though you probably
will end up getting a photo that's fine
try to connect with them as a human
being as to where don't don't start
acting stupid or I don't know geek out
on them too much because if you're in
this field you're gonna see them again
probably and so really try to make a
connection with them so anyway I'm going
there the day of I know I'm meeting JK
Simmons I know I'm inspecting his Tesla
I show up and I'm like Hannah I really
really hope to connect with him I show
up he's like here's my Tesla if you need
anything let me know and he walks inside
I'm like oh my god I'm sitting there
inspecting the Tesla
I can't think about my job at all of
course he's getting flying colors on the
Tesla trading the Tesla but then he
basically came back out and he came back
out and I was like he's like are y'all
done I'm like yeah but we need to take
the car for a drive and I came out put
this on the spot we don't have to take
it for a drive we need to take a drive
and I'm not comfortable driving your car
so you should drive I think and I'll
ride shotgun so I I got him in the car
too I got him in the car to drive him I
was like we drove around a little bit
and we were making small talk and as
soon as we get in the car I'm like I
have to say I'm a little and I wanted to
make him laugh I gotta say I'm a little
intimidated I just want watched whiplash
yesterday and just don't want you to
yell at me you know what I mean so I
that's one of the reasons I didn't want
to drive you know so I got him to laugh
right away which was good and we drove
around a bit and I was like why me I
should see what it does on the freeway
you know like and I we ended up driving
around for 45 minutes and I kept talking
to him about everything about how he
started in LA and everything that he's
done and all this kind of stuff and yeah
it's very interesting to look back on it
but I'd befriended and I ended up
actually shooting a video with him that
day because I told him was my sister my
sister's birthday was like in a couple
weeks or something but I sell them my
sister's birthday coming up is there any
way we could do like a little skit where
I'm singing her I've talked to the
camera I'm seeing her happy birthday and
then you interrupt me and go just hey do
it again
you're off-key just like the movie
because I just saw the movie and he
agreed to do it we shot the video right
there in it's like driveway that day he
thought it was cool and it was for
somebody's birthday so he was such a
nice guy and then I told them I showed
him the at the time I didn't make it
Wally
I had the trailer for parole officers
and I showed on the trailer for parole
officers and he giggled and laughed at
that and then I was like I'm making I'm
gonna make my first feature you know is
there any chance he might be able to you
know stay in touch and maybe there's a
roll in there maybe there's not and he
said yeah that'd be fun you know stay in
touch you know and I already had a cell
phone number because of the gig and so
we wrote the role in the movie for JK
Simmons that role was written for JK
Simmons and then JK Simmons was too busy
to do it he it was off in Europe doing a
movie or whatever and and so we ended up
having to find somebody to do that movie
and that's how he found Alex soul who
was a friend of Ronald Quigley and
Ronald Quigley who plays Skaggs in the
movie suggested Alex oh I didn't know
Alex was even an option I thought he was
retired but apparently he sent him the
script and once he read that part he was
in love with it and he was like I'll
I'll do whatever I have to do I'll
follow the perp to work I'll follow the
file the paperwork with sag to get out
and come back and do the movie so he
ended up doing it and yeah on on a plane
flight actually i sat next to Jimmy
Schmitz and at the time I was very young
I didn't know what to do next you know I
just moved to LA I quit worked for Todd
Phillips and and DreamWorks I knew I
wanted to act but I really had no idea
how to get started
you know I had no idea how to get
started with acting and so I asked Jimmy
Schmitz what to do and Jimmy Schmitz
said you should go to this acting
teacher and take acting classes and so I
went and
and I started acting school after that
after meeting Jimmy Schmitz on a plane
and stuff there's a lot of good ways for
people to get educated out there on how
to make it as an actor there's a book
called cracking the acting code written
by Tasha V Simpson that's a really great
book that goes over I mean and she has
been in the industry so long she
literally explains everything you need
to do from start to finish like and so
educational and it's funny because when
I first started out in in acting in LA
people would charge you for
consultations like a hundred dollars for
an hour you know and you sit down and
they tell you what you need to do and
whatever and nowadays you just need to
go buy a book like cracking the acting
code and it breaks it all down for you
and you can read it over and over again
if you want but when I was and I'm sure
there was books then too you know what I
mean
but people it's funny because our
industry so many people are making money
on the underbelly of it on acting
classes and books and all these kinds of
things and so there's so much knowledge
out there and a good way but there's
also so much knowledge out there in a
bad way that you don't know what what is
the good information and what's the bad
information and so that's one of the
reasons why I say that book is it has a
lot of value to it if you're just
starting out or I think it has chapters
to where even when you're you know at a
higher level maybe you need to break
through and you you need more knowledge
in that way as well so that's important
because I think so many books are geared
toward people just starting out but what
about people that are actually having
continuous success and then who do you
ask for help because I'm sure there's so
many so many agendas and and yeah things
people tell you yeah it's so interesting
to me because like I didn't know what a
guest star was compared to a co I don't
even can't even think of the names now
co-star role compared to a guest star
role you know I didn't know what was the
difference between a co-star role and a
guest star role you know man these are
the kind of things that you learn the
book and you should know what the what
all those things are you know you should
know out what you're going out for and
what sacrifices you know I learned like
once you going in for co-stars and you
decide to go to guest stars you don't go
back to audition for co-star so like
there's certain things like I had no
idea and I auditioned all the time but
when you you know you read somebody
Kitaj review Simpsons she's gone all the
way up the levels to learn all those
kinds of things so you can get all that
knowledge and that you just you don't
know no not a lot of people want to help
you when you get to those levels
yeah well it's funny because in the
beginning everyone was willing to help
you in and try to help you to get to
where you need to be and a lot of people
helping actually have never been there I
found that every acting teacher I ever
had had like a co-star role in a TV show
one time or something you know and
they're selling it to the to the ends of
the wheels so the people at the top of
the ladder it's very rare that they
share their knowledge you know
especially on the business side of
acting I mean the acting side a lot of
people will share but the crack in the
acting code goes over everything you
know which is a great book you can get
it at cracking the acting cracking
acting code calm you can get at Amazon
you can get it locally here at Samuel
French the bookstore and Barnes and
Nobles I think as well so you it's a lot
of places you can find that are true if
you just google it you get it on the
website or at Amazon easily but it's
rare that somebody shares their
knowledge when they're up there at the
top and about the business side of
acting which is very interesting as well
as the craft so I find that with
everything to it's funny how that that
is its artists and people they feel very
lucky to be where they are and a lot of
people that are naturally gifted they're
terrified that they have a secret and
they don't want to tell everyone the
secret everybody can do what they do
they don't realize they're naturally so
talented so they usually don't want to
share with other people or help people
get to where they are because usually
there's a self-worth there that they
don't feel secure enough to help other
people so you talked about like sharing
knowledge and and wanting to be generous
and I think that's great and I think
there are people that want to help I
think the part that gets weird is some
of the takers there's so many people
that want like you tell me how to do it
so I can just just jump start up here
and I don't have to go through and pay
my dues so I think sometimes people are
wary of that and that's very
understandable mhm because there is that
element here and then I hate to you know
throw a bucket of cold water on it but I
think that's speaking truthfully yeah
and so I think that might be sometimes
why people pull back because they're
like okay is this person they want my
help but do they really want my they are
they really going to do what I tell them
would help them or they are hoping I'm
gonna pull them up with me and all the
time I spent now I'm expecting they're
just gonna circumvent all that and come
with you know I I totally understand
that I think it's funny because a lot of
people don't want to pay their dues
we're in a world of instant
gratification when it comes to social
media when it comes to everything it's
instant gratification and the truth is
if you want to be an act if you want to
be a film director it's a career and it
takes time and I've seen the only people
that I know that are successful in the
levels of like what they wanted to do
they put fifteen years and working hard
I mean Roger V Simpson who wrote that
books she didn't work as an actress 15
years you know and and she's finally now
getting you know all the things she
wanted to get in it takes that much time
my my sister she's a big musicians easy
ward she you know she's on her third
album but her goal is to win a Grammy
you know I mean so it's like it takes so
much time to learn and to to get there
and so yeah people you get shortcuts by
learning from other people absolutely if
you can learn from other people I think
ego is a problem is the ways ego gets in
the with your greatest strengths and is
your greatest weakness in this town you
need to have everything I was talking
about us like a strong shell when people
doubt you but you can't have the ego to
think that you're not learning you know
I'm saying so if you have this strength
and belief in yourself that is great but
the moment you think you don't need
people or you don't need to learn
something that ego is your worst enemy
because you need to continue to learn
and continue to get better and that's
the belief you need to have is that
you're gonna get there and that you're
gonna learn how to get there
not that you're the the diamond that
when you walk into town that you're just
so shiny that everyone's gonna love you
because that doesn't exist you might be
really good at acting in your small town
in
and that now you're here around people
that look just like you and they're just
as talented and have more experience so
you better get the experience and the
only way for you to get that is to
believe in yourself and to keep working
hard to get it so and that's why I
worked so hard on making while II got
wasted and I hope everyone enjoys
watching it on Amazon and rents and
bison and please leave us a review we
really need reviews on Amazon it really
helps the movie and you can also reach
out to me if you want on social media
Adam William Ward on Instagram and I try
to I try to respond to all the messages
that people give to me I don't always
get a chance so if I don't I apologize
but if it's reasonable I try to say
thank you or if people have questions
answering back with the movie sometimes
I get a lot sometimes you know some days
I get none so I'll do my best
Adam William Ward on Instagram so if
people want to friend me there you go